How many cold opens are we going to be doing? We're doing one right now. We're doing one. Oh, okay. Let's start with the first one. And basically, the big question is, listener, how are you doing? Oh, God. How are you feeling out there, listener?
How many cold opens are we going to be doing? We're doing one right now. We're doing one. Oh, okay. Let's start with the first one. And basically, the big question is, listener, how are you doing? Oh, God. How are you feeling out there, listener?|||我们要做多少个开场白？我们现在就在做一个。我们在做一个。哦，好吧。我们从第一个开始吧。基本上，最大的问题是，听众朋友，你们过得怎么样？哦，天哪。你们感觉怎么样，听众朋友？
Hey, just turn this up nice and loud. Let us enter your ear hole because we're going to fill it full of. Welcome to Smartless. Yeah. Will, are you ready? Fuck. Yeah, I've been ready for fucking 20 minutes, AWOD. I mean, Will had some real technical difficulties. Sean was busy doing the Trader Joe's lobster bisque pasta. He loves that trend.
Hey, just turn this up nice and loud. Let us enter your ear hole because we're going to fill it full of. Welcome to Smartless. Yeah. Will, are you ready? Fuck. Yeah, I've been ready for fucking 20 minutes, AWOD. I mean, Will had some real technical difficulties. Sean was busy doing the Trader Joe's lobster bisque pasta. He loves that trend.|||嘿，把声音放大点。让我们钻进你的耳朵里，因为我们要把这里塞满。欢迎来到 Smartless。耶。威尔，你准备好了吗？操。对啊，我他妈20分钟前就准备好了，AWOD。我是说，威尔遇到了一些技术上的真问题。肖恩忙着弄 Trader Joe 的龙虾浓汤意面呢。他可喜欢这个潮流了。
He's all over TikTok doing the lobster best pasta trend. Sean, do you do your own grocery shopping? I don't, I, yeah, sometimes I do, yeah. What was the pause for? Can you go deeper on the pausing? Yeah. Well, cause a lot of times Scotty, thank you Scotty, just made me some tea, look at that.
He's all over TikTok doing the lobster best pasta trend. Sean, do you do your own grocery shopping? I don't, I, yeah, sometimes I do, yeah. What was the pause for? Can you go deeper on the pausing? Yeah. Well, cause a lot of times Scotty, thank you Scotty, just made me some tea, look at that.|||他在 TikTok 上到处拍龙虾浓汤意面潮流呢。肖恩，你自己去买菜吗？我没……我，对，有时候会去，对。刚才那停顿是为什么？你能深入谈谈那个停顿吗？对。呃，因为很多时候斯科蒂——谢谢你，斯科蒂——刚刚给我泡了杯茶，你看。
Yeah, no. Can he take the rest of the afternoon off? And by tea, do you mean chili? Yeah, a cup of chili. No, I do, I go to the grocery store. Scotty, do we go to the grocery store? Help me. Do we?
Yeah, no. Can he take the rest of the afternoon off? And by tea, do you mean chili? Yeah, a cup of chili. No, I do, I go to the grocery store. Scotty, do we go to the grocery store? Help me. Do we?|||行吧。他能把剩下的下午假都休了吗？你说的茶是指肉酱汤吗？对，一杯肉酱汤。不，我会去，我会去杂货店。斯科蒂，我们会去杂货店吗？救救我。会吗？
Yeah, sometimes we go to the grocery store. Wait a second. Yeah, we go to the grocery store. I'm sorry, can we just pause on that for one second? Can we pause on the, Scotty, do we go to the grocery store. I'm sorry, can we just pause on that for one second? Can we pause on the, Scotty, do we go to the grocery store sometimes? We do sometimes. But here's the thing.
Yeah, sometimes we go to the grocery store. Wait a second. Yeah, we go to the grocery store. I'm sorry, can we just pause on that for one second? Can we pause on the, Scotty, do we go to the grocery store. I'm sorry, can we just pause on that for one second? Can we pause on the, Scotty, do we go to the grocery store sometimes? We do sometimes. But here's the thing.|||对，有时候我们会去杂货店。等一下。对，我们会去杂货店。对不起，我们能暂停一秒钟吗？我们能暂停一下……斯科蒂，我们会去杂货店吗？对不起，我们能暂停一秒钟吗？我们能暂停一下……斯科蒂，我们有时候会去杂货店吗？我们有时候会去。但问题是。
Are you in a blackout? I only like to go when I know exactly what it is I need. And then like years ago, it's so funny you said this because last night I was talking about this. Years ago I thought it was great. Way to go JB, here we go, it's a great story. He does seem like he's really fired,
Are you in a blackout? I only like to go when I know exactly what it is I need. And then like years ago, it's so funny you said this because last night I was talking about this. Years ago I thought it was great. Way to go JB, here we go, it's a great story. He does seem like he's really fired,|||你失忆了吗？我只在非常清楚自己需要什么的时候才喜欢去。然后，就像几年前……你这么说太有意思了，因为昨晚我还在谈这个。几年前我觉得这太棒了。干得好，JB，我们开始吧，这是个好故事。他看起来确实挺兴奋的，
he's filled the whole gas tank ready for this one. Yeah, get into it, go ahead, go back to, take us back to years ago. Yeah, I had this idea for this app, which was, I was going to partner with all of these grocery stores, and when you walk into the grocery store, your phone recognizes your location, and then it gives you a map of that grocery store,
he's filled the whole gas tank ready for this one. Yeah, get into it, go ahead, go back to, take us back to years ago. Yeah, I had this idea for this app, which was, I was going to partner with all of these grocery stores, and when you walk into the grocery store, your phone recognizes your location, and then it gives you a map of that grocery store,|||油箱都加满了，准备好讲这个了。对，切入正题吧，继续，回到……带我们回到几年前。对，我当时有个关于这个应用的创意，就是，我要和所有这些杂货店合作，当你走进杂货店时，你的手机能识别你的位置，然后给你提供那家杂货店的地图，
and you put in what exactly you're looking for, so you're not in there for an hour just looking for the one item. Some people just fill a post-it. So instead of looking at the signs above, you just look at your phone. That's right. And then somebody thought of it,
and you put in what exactly you're looking for, so you're not in there for an hour just looking for the one item. Some people just fill a post-it. So instead of looking at the signs above, you just look at your phone. That's right. And then somebody thought of it,|||然后你输入你具体在找什么东西，这样你就不用在里面找一个东西花上一小时了。有些人直接就写满一张便利贴。所以与其看上面的指示牌，你不如看手机。没错。然后有人想到了这个点子，
and somebody's doing it. And they're bankrupt already. Yeah. I went to, I remember one time being in Germany and seeing these stores, they had these food stores, where you go in, true story, and they'd have like set up in different areas of the store, examples of prepared meals, like a pasta,
and somebody's doing it. And they're bankrupt already. Yeah. I went to, I remember one time being in Germany and seeing these stores, they had these food stores, where you go in, true story, and they'd have like set up in different areas of the store, examples of prepared meals, like a pasta,|||而且已经有人在做了。结果他们已经破产了。对。我去过……我记得有一次在德国看到这些商店，他们有一些食品店，你走进去——千真万确的故事——他们在店里的不同区域摆放了预制菜的样品，比如意面，
like a chicken or whatever, and then all the way around that item, and they would switch them up every day, they'd have all the necessary ingredients that you need to buy from the store just to make that at home. Pretty good. You don't like that? Yeah, you know what, something I to make that at home. Pretty good. You don't like that?
like a chicken or whatever, and then all the way around that item, and they would switch them up every day, they'd have all the necessary ingredients that you need to buy from the store just to make that at home. Pretty good. You don't like that? Yeah, you know what, something I to make that at home. Pretty good. You don't like that?|||比如鸡肉什么的，然后在这个样品的周围，他们每天都会换样，摆满了你在店里需要买的所有必需食材，好让你回家自己做。挺不错的。你不喜欢这样吗？对，你知道吗，我……回家做那个。挺不错的。你不喜欢吗？
Yeah, you know what, something I would do that. I would buy that. You know what else they do at supermarkets is they've got rows and rows and rows of ingredients that you could buy to build the thing you just tasted. This is kind of eliminating the like, oh, what do I need? I need to go and eat, no, no, no, all of it's right there.
Yeah, you know what, something I would do that. I would buy that. You know what else they do at supermarkets is they've got rows and rows and rows of ingredients that you could buy to build the thing you just tasted. This is kind of eliminating the like, oh, what do I need? I need to go and eat, no, no, no, all of it's right there.|||对，你知道吗，我会这么做。我会买那个。你知道超市里还做什么吗？他们有一排又一排的食材，你可以买来做出你刚尝过的那个东西。这有点消除了那种“哦，我需要什么？我要去吃……”的纠结，不，不，不，全都在那儿呢。
I can't wait for this answer. I can't wait for this answer Jason by the way standing in front of his huge glass house Let me tell you something I actually really enjoy the market and when I go It's expensive because I will I'll take three hours and I'll just go aisle to aisle last time Oh, yeah, and then that's to aisle. Up and then down. And then up and then, this was 87, 88. We're talking very recent. Sometimes I need a follow card, you know, because the front one gets too thick. Lettuce and romaine lettuce and butter lettuce.
I can't wait for this answer. I can't wait for this answer Jason by the way standing in front of his huge glass house Let me tell you something I actually really enjoy the market and when I go It's expensive because I will I'll take three hours and I'll just go aisle to aisle last time Oh, yeah, and then that's to aisle. Up and then down. And then up and then, this was 87, 88. We're talking very recent. Sometimes I need a follow card, you know, because the front one gets too thick. Lettuce and romaine lettuce and butter lettuce.|||我等不及要听这个回答了。我等不及这个回答了，詹森顺便站在他巨大的玻璃房前。我跟你说，我其实挺喜欢逛市场的，而且我去的时候花销很大，因为我会花三个小时，在每个过道里穿梭，上次……哦，对，然后就是过道。先上去，再下来。再上去，再……这是87、88年的事了。我们说的是非常近期的事。有时候我需要一张跟进卡，你知道的，因为前面的卡太厚了。生菜、罗马生菜还有奶油生菜。
This is in the day where I'd get everything. Because I grew up in a house that was very, very sort of, quote, healthy, you know, so there wasn't any garbage in the day where I'd get everything. Because I grew up in a house that was very, very, sort of, quote, healthy, so there wasn't any garbage in the house, and so once I moved out, I bought all the garbage. I mean, the snacks, the sodas, the cereals. It's almost like when you get older and you're on your own, something feels good about not having to ask permission
This is in the day where I'd get everything. Because I grew up in a house that was very, very sort of, quote, healthy, you know, so there wasn't any garbage in the day where I'd get everything. Because I grew up in a house that was very, very, sort of, quote, healthy, you know, so there wasn't any garbage in the house, and so once I moved out, I bought all the garbage. I mean, the snacks, the sodas, the cereals. It's almost like when you get older and you're on your own, something feels good about not having to ask permission|||那是我什么都买的时期。因为我是在一个非常、非常可以说是“健康”的家庭里长大的，你知道的，所以家里没有任何垃圾食品……那是我什么都买的时期。因为我是在一个非常、非常可以说是“健康”的家庭里长大的，你知道的，所以家里没有任何垃圾食品，以至于我一搬出去，就把所有的垃圾食品都买了个遍。我是说，零食、苏打水、麦片。这简直就像当你年纪大了，开始自己生活时，不用请求允许就能吃任何你想吃的东西，这种感觉真的很爽。
to get eaten, whatever you want. Let's be clear, Sean, I grew out of it in about two years. And I've been taking care of my body ever since. You're, what, 62, 63 now? And you're still buying Froot Loops. No, I will have something like that on occasion. I'm trying to, now I'm trying to find balance for the first time ever.
to get eaten, whatever you want. Let's be clear, Sean, I grew out of it in about two years. And I've been taking care of my body ever since. You're, what, 62, 63 now? And you're still buying Froot Loops. No, I will have something like that on occasion. I'm trying to, now I'm trying to find balance for the first time ever.|||把想吃的东西都吃了。说清楚点，肖恩，我大概两年后就改掉这个习惯了。从那以后我一直在照顾自己的身体。你现在多少岁来着，62、63岁了？结果你还在买果圈麦片。不，我偶尔会吃点那种东西。我正在努力……现在我第一次尝试寻找平衡。
Are you still off sugar? You were off sugar a couple weeks ago. Not entirely, but I didn't realize my favorite ice cream had 100 grams of sugar in a pint. Didn't realize that, huh? What do you think? Do you think ice cream is just unicorn farts and cream? Yeah, I didn't know they could manufacture unicorn farts.
Are you still off sugar? You were off sugar a couple weeks ago. Not entirely, but I didn't realize my favorite ice cream had 100 grams of sugar in a pint. Didn't realize that, huh? What do you think? Do you think ice cream is just unicorn farts and cream? Yeah, I didn't know they could manufacture unicorn farts.|||你还在戒糖吗？你几周前还在戒糖呢。不完全是，但我没意识到我最喜欢的冰淇淋一品脱里竟然有100克糖。之前没意识到，是吧？你觉得呢？你以为冰淇淋只是独角兽的屁和奶油吗？对啊，我不知道他们还能生产独角兽的屁。
Yeah, it's cream and sugar. Full stop. Yeah. What kind of dad joke do I have for you? This might have been, I'd love to just transition into our guest. This is a new, this is just a new segment. Wait, this one, because I don't know if,
Yeah, it's cream and sugar. Full stop. Yeah. What kind of dad joke do I have for you? This might have been, I'd love to just transition into our guest. This is a new, this is just a new segment. Wait, this one, because I don't know if,|||对，就是奶油和糖。句号。对。我有什么冷笑话要讲给你听呢？这可能是……我很想直接过渡到我们的嘉宾。这是一个新的，这只是一个新的环节。等等，这个，因为我不知道……
I may have said this before. You've created your own segment here. I may have said this before, so please forgive me if I told you this one, all right. But I asked my brother to pass me the travel pamphlet this morning. Yeah. And he said, bro, sure.
I may have said this before. You've created your own segment here. I may have said this before, so please forgive me if I told you this one, all right. But I asked my brother to pass me the travel pamphlet this morning. Yeah. And he said, bro, sure.|||我可能以前说过这个。你自己在这里创造了一个环节。我可能以前说过这个，所以如果我跟你讲过这个笑话，请原谅我，好吗？但是我今天早上让我弟弟把旅游小册子递给我。对。然后他说，兄弟，当然（bro, sure / 谐音 brochures 宣传册）。
the travel pamphlet this morning, and he said, bro, sure. Oh, I gotta giggle, I gotta giggle. JB really likes that one. JB really likes that one. That one makes me real happy, it settles me. It's good that it settles me because I'm really nervous about this next guest. I mean, you know, this is...
the travel pamphlet this morning, and he said, bro, sure. Oh, I gotta giggle, I gotta giggle. JB really likes that one. JB really likes that one. That one makes me real happy, it settles me. It's good that it settles me because I'm really nervous about this next guest. I mean, you know, this is...|||我今天早上让我弟弟把旅游小册子递给我，然后他说，兄弟，当然。哦，我得笑一个，我得笑一个。JB真的很喜欢那个。JB真的很喜欢那个。那个让我真的很开心，让我平静下来。它能让我平静下来真是太好了，因为我对接下来的这位嘉宾感到非常紧张。我是说，你知道的，这是……
Is that why you wear a nice shirt? Yeah, exactly. I don't think you've ever seen me in a button-up on this show. Really nice. So today's guest, this is someone I've wanted to meet for a very long time. She first hit my radar, oh no wait, that's...
Is that why you wear a nice shirt? Yeah, exactly. I don't think you've ever seen me in a button-up on this show. Really nice. So today's guest, this is someone I've wanted to meet for a very long time. She first hit my radar, oh no wait, that's...|||这就是你穿一件漂亮衬衫的原因吗？对，完全正确。我想你从来没在这个节目里看我穿过系扣衬衫。真的很不错。所以今天的嘉宾，这是我一直非常想见的人。她进入我的视线时……哦不，等等，那是……
That's my wife. That's the last guest. It's Amanda. Hey, God, can you imagine how much shit you'd throw at me if I came this unprepared? And by the way, what a swipe to your guest. I'm wearing a nice shirt though. What a side swipe to your guest.
That's my wife. That's the last guest. It's Amanda. Hey, God, can you imagine how much shit you'd throw at me if I came this unprepared? And by the way, what a swipe to your guest. I'm wearing a nice shirt though. What a side swipe to your guest.|||那是我的妻子。那是上一位嘉宾。是阿曼达。嘿，天哪，如果我准备得这么不充分，你能想象你会怎么狠狠地数落我吗？顺便说一句，这对手头嘉宾可真是一个沉重的打击。不过我确实穿着一件漂亮的衬衫。这对手头嘉宾可真是一个大大的讽刺。
Oh no, here we go, here we go, here we go. Oh, that's it. What if it started exactly the same? I would have gone already. If I were your guest. Oh no, here we go, here we go, here we go. This is just unreal. I would be livid. What if it started exactly the same? I would have hung up, I would have gone already. If I were your guest, I would have walked. We've got a real special treat today, Dash, I think. Can't wait to meet her. This is someone who I've been watching from afar,
Oh no, here we go, here we go, here we go. Oh, that's it. What if it started exactly the same? I would have gone already. If I were your guest. Oh no, here we go, here we go, here we go. This is just unreal. I would be livid. What if it started exactly the same? I would have hung up, I would have gone already. If I were your guest, I would have walked. We've got a real special treat today, Dash, I think. Can't wait to meet her. This is someone who I've been watching from afar,|||哦不，开始了，开始了，开始了。哦，就是这样。如果开头完全一样呢？我早就走了。如果我是你的嘉宾。哦不，开始了，开始了，开始了。这简直太离谱了。我会气炸的。如果开头完全一样呢？我早就挂电话了，我早就走了。如果我是你的嘉宾，我早就甩手走人了。我们今天有一个非常特别的惊喜，达什，我想是的。迫不及待想见她。这是一位我一直在远远关注的人，
very, very curious about. She is stalking. Stalking. She's a true chameleon. She started acting at 15 and now barely 30. She's already won multiple Emmys, countless nominations, and seems positioned for a long and fruitful career. How did this Hebrew-speaking beauty from the Bronx
very, very curious about. She is stalking. Stalking. She's a true chameleon. She started acting at 15 and now barely 30. She's already won multiple Emmys, countless nominations, and seems positioned for a long and fruitful career. How did this Hebrew-speaking beauty from the Bronx|||对她非常非常好奇。她在跟踪。跟踪。她是一个真正的变色龙。她15岁开始演戏，现在刚满30岁。她已经赢得了多次艾美奖，无数次提名，并且似乎注定会拥有漫长而硕果累累的职业生涯。这个来自布朗克斯的说希伯来语的美女是如何
make it all the way out to Hollywood and into our hearts? Guys, let's find out. This is Miss Julia Garner. Did I say that correctly? Did I pronounce that right? You threw me with I can't wait to meet her. Oh, right? A real crafty like that.
make it all the way out to Hollywood and into our hearts? Guys, let's find out. This is Miss Julia Garner. Did I say that correctly? Did I pronounce that right? You threw me with I can't wait to meet her. Oh, right? A real crafty like that.|||一路闯进好莱坞并走进我们心里的？伙计们，让我们一探究竟。这位是朱莉娅·加纳女士。我没说错吧？我发音对了吗？你一句“我迫不及待想见她”把我给整懵了。哦，是吧？真够狡猾的。
We can unblock the camera now, my sweet love. Yeah. Oh, there you are. Hi. Hi, Julia. Oh, you look just like on the TV shows. Oh my God. It's so nice to meet you, Jason.
We can unblock the camera now, my sweet love. Yeah. Oh, there you are. Hi. Hi, Julia. Oh, you look just like on the TV shows. Oh my God. It's so nice to meet you, Jason.|||我们现在可以解除摄像头屏蔽了，我亲爱的。对。哦，你在这儿呢。嗨。嗨，朱莉娅。哦，你看起来跟电视上长得一模一样。哦天哪。很高兴见到你，詹森。
You too. I've heard so much about you. Wait, no Southern accent? No Southern accent. So that was just a put on from the... So that our listener knows, Julia starred in, was arguably the best part of Ozark for the entire... You're right.
You too. I've heard so much about you. Wait, no Southern accent? No Southern accent. So that was just a put on from the... So that our listener knows, Julia starred in, was arguably the best part of Ozark for the entire... You're right.|||我也是。久仰大名。等等，没有南方口音？没有南方口音。所以那只是……为了让我们的听众知道，朱莉娅主演了《黑钱胜地》，可以说是整部剧中最精彩的部分，长达……你说得对。
For years and years, and that's how you and JB met, I presume, was on Ozark, the award-winning show brought to you by our very own JB and starring the wonderful Julia Garner. Julia, welcome to Smarless. And Jason. Jason, starring Jason. Brought to you by our friend Ted Sarandos. That's who brought it to us. Oh my God.
For years and years, and that's how you and JB met, I presume, was on Ozark, the award-winning show brought to you by our very own JB and starring the wonderful Julia Garner. Julia, welcome to Smarless. And Jason. Jason, starring Jason. Brought to you by our friend Ted Sarandos. That's who brought it to us. Oh my God.|||多年来都是如此，我想你和JB就是在那部由我们自己的JB带给各位并由精彩的朱莉娅·加纳主演的获奖剧集《黑钱胜地》上结识的吧。朱莉娅，欢迎来到 Smarless。还有詹森。詹森，由詹森主演。由我们的朋友泰德·萨兰多斯为您呈现。就是他把这剧带给我们的。哦天哪。
Huck her up. Yeah. I love you, Teddy. Teddy, you're the best. Gross. Disgusting. Go ahead. You know what, though, Julia? First of all, so nice to meet you, Teddy. Teddy, you're the best. Gross. Love you, Nina. You know what though, Julia? First of all, it's so nice to meet you.
Huck her up. Yeah. I love you, Teddy. Teddy, you're the best. Gross. Disgusting. Go ahead. You know what, though, Julia? First of all, so nice to meet you, Teddy. Teddy, you're the best. Gross. Love you, Nina. You know what though, Julia? First of all, it's so nice to meet you.|||夸夸她。对。我爱你，泰迪。泰迪，你最棒了。真恶心。太令人作呕了。继续。不过你知道吗，朱莉娅？首先，很高兴见到你，泰迪。泰迪，你最棒了。真恶心。爱你的，妮娜。不过你知道吗，朱莉娅？首先，很高兴见到你。
So nice to meet you. This is really cool. Jason was joking because I know every interview you've ever given over the many, many years of Ozark was about that accent, but I was truly blown away. Because I had never seen you before, because I'm an idiot. A lot of people.
So nice to meet you. This is really cool. Jason was joking because I know every interview you've ever given over the many, many years of Ozark was about that accent, but I was truly blown away. Because I had never seen you before, because I'm an idiot. A lot of people.|||很高兴见到你。这真的很酷。詹森是在开玩笑，因为我知道你在《黑钱胜地》漫长的多年里接受的每一次采访都是关于那个口音的，但我真的被惊艳到了。因为我以前从来没见过你，因为我是个白痴。很多人都这样。
My first exposure to you was Ozark. And then when I saw you on your first talk show, I was like I had never seen you before so because I'm an idiot and my first exposure my first exposure to you was Ozark and then when I saw you on your first talk show I was like oh wait what like it was it was so believable you were completely do you love playing characters like that thing he's he's really blown away by the concept of it it's so fun right Sean? When you pretend to be someone else, is it neat? Yeah. Yeah, I guess. I mean... He thought Ozark was a documentary, sorry. He just... Jason just brought a whole film crew to the last Ozarks.
My first exposure to you was Ozark. And then when I saw you on your first talk show, I was like I had never seen you before so because I'm an idiot and my first exposure my first exposure to you was Ozark and then when I saw you on your first talk show I was like oh wait what like it was it was so believable you were completely do you love playing characters like that thing he's he's really blown away by the concept of it it's so fun right Sean? When you pretend to be someone else, is it neat? Yeah. Yeah, I guess. I mean... He thought Ozark was a documentary, sorry. He just... Jason just brought a whole film crew to the last Ozarks.|||我第一次认识你就是通过《黑钱胜地》。然后当我在你的第一个脱口秀节目中看到你时，我想……我以前从来没见过你，因为我是个白痴，我第一次接触……我第一次接触你就是通过《黑钱胜地》，然后当我在第一个脱口秀上看到你时，我就想：哦等等，什么？就像是——太逼真了，你完全……你喜欢扮演那样的角色吗？他真的被这个概念给震撼到了，这太有趣了，对吧，肖恩？当你假装成另一个人时，是不是很酷？对。对，我猜吧。我是说……他以为《黑钱胜地》是个纪录片，抱歉。他只是……詹森在拍上一季《黑钱胜地》时带了整个摄制组过去。
Disturbed you and your brothers? Just did like, Werner Herzog style, basically. I don't think I ever asked you, was it... It would have been fun for me I would be fun one day to play to play and do some big southern action. Yeah Why don't you do it like was it fun to do that? Hang on keep going The truck yeah
Disturbed you and your brothers? Just did like, Werner Herzog style, basically. I don't think I ever asked you, was it... It would have been fun for me I would be fun one day to play to play and do some big southern action. Yeah Why don't you do it like was it fun to do that? Hang on keep going The truck yeah|||打扰了你和你的兄弟们？基本上就是搞得像沃纳·赫尔佐格的风格一样。我想我从来没问过你，那是……对我来说会很有趣，如果有一天能去演、去搞点什么盛大的南方动作戏就好了。对，你为什么不……那样做有趣吗？等等，继续。卡车，对。
Is it fun to play to use the accent all the time? Did I use it, like, off camera when we weren't working together? No, no, no. No, no, no. When you were doing it, when you were playing the Ruth Langmore gal there. Was it a, was it a, was it work or did you enjoy actually doing that? Because you have to be conscious of it. It was both, but I feel like if you want anything
Is it fun to play to use the accent all the time? Did I use it, like, off camera when we weren't working together? No, no, no. No, no, no. When you were doing it, when you were playing the Ruth Langmore gal there. Was it a, was it a, was it work or did you enjoy actually doing that? Because you have to be conscious of it. It was both, but I feel like if you want anything|||一直用那种口音演戏有趣吗？我在镜头外、我们不一起工作的时候也用过吗？不，不，不。不，不，不。当你在做这件事时，当你扮演露丝·兰莫尔那个姑娘时。这到底是一项工作，还是你真的很享受这么做？因为你必须时刻注意它。两者兼而有之吧，但我觉得如果你想把任何事情——
to be good, it takes a lot of work. Yeah, yeah. And also just think. I'm writing this down as you're talking. Yeah, but also it's like, also if you want, you know, I'm always constantly like chasing that flow state, so, and that takes a lot of work in a way. The flow state is. To just kind of get there. What and that takes a lot of work in a way.
to be good, it takes a lot of work. Yeah, yeah. And also just think. I'm writing this down as you're talking. Yeah, but also it's like, also if you want, you know, I'm always constantly like chasing that flow state, so, and that takes a lot of work in a way. The flow state is. To just kind of get there. What and that takes a lot of work in a way.|||做好，都需要付出很多努力。对，对。还有，想想看。你说话的时候我正在把它记下来。对，但同时这也是……而且如果你想的话，你知道的，我一直在不断地追寻那种心流状态，所以，这在某种程度上需要付出很多努力。心流状态就是……要达到那种状态。什么，这在某种程度上需要付出很多努力。
To just kind of get there. What is that? That is after work. Like when you're acting. Right. Well I don't know the terms. Remember when you directed me? Yeah, yeah, but the flow, but the flow happens,
To just kind of get there. What is that? That is after work. Like when you're acting. Right. Well I don't know the terms. Remember when you directed me? Yeah, yeah, but the flow, but the flow happens,|||就是去达到那种状态。那是什么？那是收工之后。就像你在演戏的时候。对。好吧，我不懂这些专业术语。还记得你导演我的时候吗？对，对，但是心流，但是心流发生的时候，
does the flow happen after massive preparation one can reach a flow state because you've properly prepared? Question? Yes. So I like prepare, I prepare, prepare, and then once I, you know, get to your set, I just throw it all away.
does the flow happen after massive preparation one can reach a flow state because you've properly prepared? Question? Yes. So I like prepare, I prepare, prepare, and then once I, you know, get to your set, I just throw it all away.|||心流是不是在做了大量的准备工作之后才能达到，因为你做了充分的准备，所以能进入心流状态？提问？是的。所以我喜欢准备，我不断地准备、准备，然后一旦我，你知道的，到了你的片场，我就把这一切全都抛到脑后。
Yeah. You don't have to think about it. Yeah. I don't think about it. He doesn't take you out of that flow state when you see his face. It doesn't like go like... No, you know what? I love working with Jason because he kind of, I love working with Jason because he relaxes everybody. Like he makes it fun. Because sometimes when,
Yeah. You don't have to think about it. Yeah. I don't think about it. He doesn't take you out of that flow state when you see his face. It doesn't like go like... No, you know what? I love working with Jason because he kind of, I love working with Jason because he relaxes everybody. Like he makes it fun. Because sometimes when,|||对。你根本不用去想它。对。我不想它。当你看到他的脸时，他不会把你从那种心流状态中带出来吧？不会像那种……不，你知道吗？我喜欢和詹森合作，因为他有点……我喜欢和詹森合作，因为他能让所有人都放松下来。他能让过程变得很有趣。因为有时候，
especially when I was like a new actor, I would always get super tense and it felt like almost like life or death and then Jason would do something ridiculous to kind of ease it. And I loved it and I think that's so important in my opinion. I love it. You are the best. You really are.
especially when I was like a new actor, I would always get super tense and it felt like almost like life or death and then Jason would do something ridiculous to kind of ease it. And I loved it and I think that's so important in my opinion. I love it. You are the best. You really are.|||特别是当我还是个新手演员的时候，我总是会超级紧张，感觉就像生死攸关一样，然后詹森就会做一些荒谬的事情来缓解这种紧张。我很喜欢这样，在我看来这太重要了。我太喜欢了。你最棒了。你真的是。
I say this to everybody, truly. Yeah. Julie, I love that. Me too. Never been directed by him. The... Jen Sarandos is the best. Jen Sarandos is also the best.
I say this to everybody, truly. Yeah. Julie, I love that. Me too. Never been directed by him. The... Jen Sarandos is the best. Jen Sarandos is also the best.|||我真的对每个人都这么说。对。朱莉娅，我太喜欢这个了。我也是。从来没被他导演过。那个……简·萨兰多斯是最棒的。简·萨兰多斯也是最棒的。
Yeah. Let me just say that. Yeah. No, no, no. But Jay, why don't you, you never ever have, by the way, neither of you, Will, you don't either never show any signs of anxiety while me and Julia are walking around with like we're nervous about showing up and doing a good job. You should look at my bowel movements. Would you?
Yeah. Let me just say that. Yeah. No, no, no. But Jay, why don't you, you never ever have, by the way, neither of you, Will, you don't either never show any signs of anxiety while me and Julia are walking around with like we're nervous about showing up and doing a good job. You should look at my bowel movements. Would you?|||对。我只想说这个。对。不，不，不。但是杰，你为什么不……你从来没有——顺便说一句，你们两个都没有，威尔，你也是——从来不表现出任何焦虑的迹象，而我和朱莉娅走来走去，好像很担心自己表现不好、工作做不好一样。你应该看看我的排便情况。要看吗？
God, can we have one episode where we don't talk Yeah. Yeah. This is, what are you talking about? Sean, you're very, you're not. No, I mean, I get nervous, like you just said, Julia, about right before you start, and is the character that I worked on, any gonna be any good, and blah, blah, blah, you know? And then once you get, but I just don't feel that from you guys, right?
God, can we have one episode where we don't talk Yeah. Yeah. This is, what are you talking about? Sean, you're very, you're not. No, I mean, I get nervous, like you just said, Julia, about right before you start, and is the character that I worked on, any gonna be any good, and blah, blah, blah, you know? And then once you get, but I just don't feel that from you guys, right?|||天哪，我们能有一期节目不聊……对。对。这到底在聊什么？肖恩，你非常……你才没有。不，我是说，我也会紧张，就像你刚才说的，朱莉娅，就在你开始之前，我塑造的角色到底好不好，等等等等，你知道吧？一旦你进入状态……但我就是从你们身上感受不到这种情绪，对吧？
Well, you know, sort of in that vein, Julia, so you do, you're gonna do Ozark. Obviously you meet Mr. Bateman. Thank you. As he makes you, I heard that Well, you know, sort of in that vein, Julia, so you're gonna do Ozark. Obviously you meet Mr. Bateman as he makes you, I heard that he made you call him. And so you go through the process of getting that gig and you show up day one on set and you know that you're playing this Southern character. Were you nervous at all about taking that first swing,
Well, you know, sort of in that vein, Julia, so you do, you're gonna do Ozark. Obviously you meet Mr. Bateman. Thank you. As he makes you, I heard that Well, you know, sort of in that vein, Julia, so you do, you're gonna do Ozark. Obviously you meet Mr. Bateman as he makes you, I heard that he made you call him. And so you go through the process of getting that gig and you show up day one on set and you know that you're playing this Southern character. Were you nervous at all about taking that first swing,|||嗯，你知道的，顺着这个思路，朱莉娅，你要去演《黑钱胜地》。显然你遇到了贝特曼先生。谢谢。当他让你——我听说……嗯，顺着这个思路，朱莉娅，你要去演《黑钱胜地》。显然你遇到了贝特曼先生，他让你——我听说他让你直接叫他名字。于是你经历了争取这个角色的过程，并在片场第一天亮相，你知道自己要扮演这个南方角色。对于完成那第一杆、|||
that first take of that first scene? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Or had you guys prepped enough and he knew? No, I was so nervous because also, first of all, I thought that I wasn't gonna get Ozark when I auditioned for it. Well, his face just sagged, so he's always got a mean look on his face.
that first take of that first scene? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Or had you guys prepped enough and he knew? No, I was so nervous because also, first of all, I thought that I wasn't gonna get Ozark when I auditioned for it. Well, his face just sagged, so he's always got a mean look on his face.|||拍摄第一个场景的第一个镜头，你紧张吗？对，对，对。还是说你们已经准备得足够充分了，他也心里有数？不，我超级紧张，因为首先，我试镜的时候觉得自己根本拿不到《黑钱胜地》这个角色。好吧，他的脸直接耷拉下来了，所以他脸上总是挂着一副刻薄的表情。
No, it wasn't even, I actually felt, the first audition, this is him smiling, right? Look at his nose getting up, he's like got a meat hook on his face. I actually felt, the first audition, look at his nose getting up, he's like, mm-hmm. He thinks he's smiling. He has to turn his whole head up, smiling. Yeah, he's just like, look at him, it's like, I can see a booger right there. No, but it was kind of crazy because the first audition,
No, it wasn't even, I actually felt, the first audition, this is him smiling, right? Look at his nose getting up, he's like got a meat hook on his face. I actually felt, the first audition, look at his nose getting up, he's like, mm-hmm. He thinks he's smiling. He has to turn his whole head up, smiling. Yeah, he's just like, look at him, it's like, I can see a booger right there. No, but it was kind of crazy because the first audition,|||不，甚至都不是……我其实觉得，第一次试镜时——这就是他在笑对吧？看他的鼻子往上翘，脸上就像挂了个肉钩子。我其实觉得，第一次试镜时——看他的鼻子往上翘，他就像是，“嗯哼”。他以为自己在笑。他得把整个脑袋抬起来才叫笑。对，他就是那种——看他那样，就像是，我能看到那儿有个鼻屎。不，但这有点疯狂，因为第一次试镜时，
I thought, you know, it was just like a tiny, tiny casting room in New York, paper thin walls, and I'm like hearing the other actors read the lines and I'm like, oh my God. That's the worst. Yeah, and I'm like, wow, she killed it. And they're like, that was amazing, that was fantastic. And then I had to go in next and I did it once. And I remember calling my mother and I was like, I'm not, I don't think I'm, I'm just
I thought, you know, it was just like a tiny, tiny casting room in New York, paper thin walls, and I'm like hearing the other actors read the lines and I'm like, oh my God. That's the worst. Yeah, and I'm like, wow, she killed it. And they're like, that was amazing, that was fantastic. And then I had to go in next and I did it once. And I remember calling my mother and I was like, I'm not, I don't think I'm, I'm just|||我以为，你知道的，那只是纽约一个超级小的选角房间，墙壁薄得像纸一样，我能听到其他演员在读台词，当时我就想：哦天哪。那是相当糟糕。对，然后我就想：哇，她演得太绝了。他们就说：太棒了，太精彩了。然后轮到我进去，我演了一遍。我记得我当时打电话给我妈，我说我不会……我觉得我不会……我只是……
going to move on. And then I want to say like 10 days later, there was a callback and Jason was in that callback and I remember the, I remember he- Slower. He kept it. No, I'm trying. No, I'm just- Sean. I remember he... Slower. I'm trying to make up a story that...
going to move on. And then I want to say like 10 days later, there was a callback and Jason was in that callback and I remember the, I remember he- Slower. He kept it. No, I'm trying. No, I'm just- Sean. I remember he... Slower. I'm trying to make up a story that...|||打算放弃了。然后差不多10天后，有了一次复试，詹森也参加了那次复试，我记得……我记得他——慢点。他保持住了。不，我在努力。不，我只是……肖恩。我记得他……慢点。我在努力编一个……
He gave very good, he gave amazing, like really interesting direction, but also he was very sweet. And then he started talking about like local TV at the end of the audition. Local news. You were saying, what are you going to do later? I was like, I don't know. Watch some TV. And he's like, what are you going to watch? Local news. That was... That is funny.
He gave very good, he gave amazing, like really interesting direction, but also he was very sweet. And then he started talking about like local TV at the end of the audition. Local news. You were saying, what are you going to do later? I was like, I don't know. Watch some TV. And he's like, what are you going to watch? Local news. That was... That is funny.|||他给出了非常好、非常惊艳、非常有趣的指导，而且他人也特别好。然后在试镜结束时，他开始聊起了当地的电视节目。当地新闻。你当时说，你待会儿打算干嘛？我说，我不知道。看会电视呗。他问，你要看什么？当地新闻。那是……这太搞笑了。
That's literally the first thing. And then I was like, that guy's an oddball, but I like him. And I was like, but also how does he know that I kind of like love secretly local news too? He saw me, like immediately. Yes, yes. Did I say any, I didn't, we didn't, I didn't say hey high five you got the job in the room, did I? No, no and Chris was in the room and I just remember feeling like still unsure.
That's literally the first thing. And then I was like, that guy's an oddball, but I like him. And I was like, but also how does he know that I kind of like love secretly local news too? He saw me, like immediately. Yes, yes. Did I say any, I didn't, we didn't, I didn't say hey high five you got the job in the room, did I? No, no and Chris was in the room and I just remember feeling like still unsure.|||这简直是第一件事。然后我就想：这家伙是个怪胎，但我挺喜欢他。然后我想：话说回来，他怎么知道我也暗地里挺喜欢看当地新闻的？他一下子就把我看穿了。对，对。我说过什么吗？我没有，我们没有……我没有在房间里说“嘿，击个掌，你被录用了”吧？没有，没有，克里斯当时也在房间里，我只记得自己当时还是觉得没底。
But I do remember with the first, it was like a mock scene. It wasn't even in the script. But I do remember seeing- Did I read with you? Yeah, you read with me. I did. And I remember the first scene that I saw, I was like, this dialogue's either gonna work
But I do remember with the first, it was like a mock scene. It wasn't even in the script. But I do remember seeing- Did I read with you? Yeah, you read with me. I did. And I remember the first scene that I saw, I was like, this dialogue's either gonna work|||但我确实记得第一场戏，那就像是个模拟场景。甚至都不在剧本里。但我确实记得看到——是我跟你搭戏吗？对，你跟我搭戏。是的。我记得我看到的第一个场景，我就想：这段台词要么就是……
if this person talks really fast or really slow. There was no in between. That was always very clear in the dialogue, I feel like. And you went with the fast. Depending on her mood. Yeah. And then what about the accent? Was that something that Alexa Fogle,
if this person talks really fast or really slow. There was no in between. That was always very clear in the dialogue, I feel like. And you went with the fast. Depending on her mood. Yeah. And then what about the accent? Was that something that Alexa Fogle,|||只要这个人说话语速极快或者极慢，它就能行得通。没有中间状态。我觉得这一点在台词里一直非常清晰。而你选择了极快。取决于她的心情。对。那口音呢？那是阿历克萨·福格尔——
sort of our casting director, did she give you a sort of a hint, a tip on that? Like you should speak, or is that just something you did on your own? No, by the way, we love Alexa Fogle. Shout out to Alexa Fogle. Shout out to Alexa Fogle. Yes, like grateful for Alexa.
sort of our casting director, did she give you a sort of a hint, a tip on that? Like you should speak, or is that just something you did on your own? No, by the way, we love Alexa Fogle. Shout out to Alexa Fogle. Shout out to Alexa Fogle. Yes, like grateful for Alexa.|||也就是我们的选角导演——她给你提供了一些暗示或建议吗？比如你应该怎么说，还是说这完全是你自己琢磨出来的？不，顺便说一句，我们超爱阿历克萨·福格尔。向阿历克萨·福格尔致敬。向阿历克萨·福格尔致敬。是的，非常感激阿历克萨。
She loves that well, Arnett. I've known her many years. Yeah. No, it was kind of one of those things that I just assumed because it was Missouri that there was going to be an accent. Missouri. And that's also why I didn't feel like the first audition, nobody was doing that accent.
She loves that well, Arnett. I've known her many years. Yeah. No, it was kind of one of those things that I just assumed because it was Missouri that there was going to be an accent. Missouri. And that's also why I didn't feel like the first audition, nobody was doing that accent.|||她很喜欢那样，阿奈特。我认识她很多年了。对。不，这可以说是那种我理所当然地认为因为背景是密苏里州，所以肯定会有口音的情况。密苏里。这也是为什么我觉得在第一次试镜时，根本没有人用那种口音。
And then I couldn't remember my lines with my regular speaking voice. So I started freaking out. That's why I didn't think I was going to get the job. Oh, wow. Wow. Yeah. Did you, you know, I will say it reminded me of, did you ever know people, I knew a few actors over the year, especially like in the 90s, being in New York,
And then I couldn't remember my lines with my regular speaking voice. So I started freaking out. That's why I didn't think I was going to get the job. Oh, wow. Wow. Yeah. Did you, you know, I will say it reminded me of, did you ever know people, I knew a few actors over the year, especially like in the 90s, being in New York,|||然后我用自己平常说话的声音根本记不住台词。所以我开始抓狂了。这就是为什么我觉得自己拿不到这份工作。哦，哇。哇。对。你有没有……你知道，我要说这让我想起——你认识这样的人吗？这些年来我认识一些演员，特别是在90年代身处纽约的时候，
and sometimes coming out here, and you'd often over a course of years see like the same kind of people who were kind of your age up for the similar jobs, and you'd see them over and you get to know them from waiting rooms and stuff around town. Yeah. Oh my God.
and sometimes coming out here, and you'd often over a course of years see like the same kind of people who were kind of your age up for the similar jobs, and you'd see them over and you get to know them from waiting rooms and stuff around town. Yeah. Oh my God.|||有时来到这里，多年来你经常会看到那种年龄相仿、竞争相似工作的人，你会反复看到他们，并通过城里的候诊室之类的认识他们。对。哦天哪。
That's how I had the misfortune of originally meeting Thoreau over the years was in waiting rooms. Right? There's always an actor in a waiting room. Like, yeah. But there were those, but you know those actors who would come out, I knew a couple and they thought they were being funny
That's how I had the misfortune of originally meeting Thoreau over the years was in waiting rooms. Right? There's always an actor in a waiting room. Like, yeah. But there were those, but you know those actors who would come out, I knew a couple and they thought they were being funny|||我当年不幸在候诊室里遇到梭罗就是这么认识的。对吧？候诊室里总会有一个演员。比如，对。但总有那种……但你知道有些演员出来时，我认识几个，他们觉得自己挺幽默的，
and they'd come out and they'd go like, well, I got it. Like that was their bit all the time was, I got it, nobody else. And like at a certain point you're like, hey man, just stay in your lane. Stay away from me. I'm trying to get, I wanna work too.
and they'd come out and they'd go like, well, I got it. Like that was their bit all the time was, I got it, nobody else. And like at a certain point you're like, hey man, just stay in your lane. Stay away from me. I'm trying to get, I wanna work too.|||然后他们走出来就会说：行吧，我拿下了。好像他们的梗永远都是“我拿下了，没别人份了”。然后在某个特定时刻你会想：嘿，老兄，管好你自己的事吧。离我远点。我也在争取，我也想工作。
And then cut to you walking out of the Arrested Development audition and everyone and all the executives following you out saying, all right, we got it, we got our guy, as you guys all walked past the remaining guys that were supposed to go in and audition for your part. Why did they do that? Which, if you remember, JB, at the time,
And then cut to you walking out of the Arrested Development audition and everyone and all the executives following you out saying, all right, we got it, we got our guy, as you guys all walked past the remaining guys that were supposed to go in and audition for your part. Why did they do that? Which, if you remember, JB, at the time,|||镜头一转，你从《发展受阻》的试镜室走出来，所有人和高管都跟在你后面出来，说：“行了，我们搞定了，我们找到我们要找的人了”，而你们所有人就从那些本该进去为你的角色试镜的剩下的人身边走过。他们为什么要那样做？如果你还记得的话，JB，当时，
I said to Mitch, I said, hey, let's keep it down. It was part of the story because one of the people was out there in the room who didn't get it and I felt I knew what that feeling was. Yeah. Well, we can say who knew what that feeling was. Yeah. Well, we can say who that is, because he did just fine. Rainn Wilson went on to get the office
I said to Mitch, I said, hey, let's keep it down. It was part of the story because one of the people was out there in the room who didn't get it and I felt I knew what that feeling was. Yeah. Well, we can say who knew what that feeling was. Yeah. Well, we can say who that is, because he did just fine. Rainn Wilson went on to get the office|||我对米奇说，我说：嘿，小声点。这也是故事的一部分，因为外面房间里有个人没被选上，我觉得我懂那种感觉是什么样的。对。好吧，我们可以说说谁懂那种感觉。对。好吧，我们可以说那是谁，因为他后来也混得很好。雷恩·威尔逊后来拿下了《办公室》里的角色……
a couple weeks later. Yeah, he would have beat me at that gig. So like, you know what I mean? Let's just be clear about that. Anyway, so that kind of like actor politics is always weird. Well, it's funny, and I feel like that's slowly disappearing. Like, I feel like I was kind of the last,
a couple weeks later. Yeah, he would have beat me at that gig. So like, you know what I mean? Let's just be clear about that. Anyway, so that kind of like actor politics is always weird. Well, it's funny, and I feel like that's slowly disappearing. Like, I feel like I was kind of the last,|||几周后。对，他当时要是接了那部戏，我就得被他比下去了。所以，你知道我的意思吧？咱们就把话说清楚。总之，这种演员之间的勾心斗角总是很诡异。嗯，挺有意思的，而且我觉得这种现象正在慢慢消失。就像，我觉得我算是最后一批……
the very, very last of, like there's so many actors that are working today that I've met in audition rooms when I was like 16, 17 years old. And then like there would be like a hangout after, like, oh yeah, do you like want to hang out? Yeah, like it was just like a little more, there was like, it's spontaneous a little more now.
the very, very last of, like there's so many actors that are working today that I've met in audition rooms when I was like 16, 17 years old. And then like there would be like a hangout after, like, oh yeah, do you like want to hang out? Yeah, like it was just like a little more, there was like, it's spontaneous a little more now.|||绝对、绝对最后一批了——现在有很多活跃的演员，我早在自己16、17岁时就在试镜室里见过他们了。然后面试结束后还会有一场聚会什么的，比如，“哦对了，你想一起出去玩吗？”对，就像是稍微多了一点……现在稍微多了一点随性。
It's just, yeah. But you were also, but you're also, you were a great hanger outer on Ozark, right? You guys, you always went out. I don't even know what that means. Well, but because you always, I would always hear the next morning at work, like you guys would all talk about the night you guys had out,
It's just, yeah. But you were also, but you're also, you were a great hanger outer on Ozark, right? You guys, you always went out. I don't even know what that means. Well, but because you always, I would always hear the next morning at work, like you guys would all talk about the night you guys had out,|||就是这样，对。但你也是……但你也是个在《黑钱胜地》剧组很会社交的人，对吧？你们这群人，总是出去玩。我都不知道那是什么意思。嗯，但因为你总是……我第二天早上上班时总会听到，你们大家都在讨论前一天晚上的外出聚会，
you'd go out with all the other actors and you guys would all have a lot of fun I was also 22 when I started a real life down there You know you JB granddad went home put on the comfy socks and PJs and watch Rachel Maddow and learn my lines and went to bed Still doing the same thing today Over no regrets. What have you haven't missed anything. It's all going to be over. No regrets. What have you done? Nothing!
you'd go out with all the other actors and you guys would all have a lot of fun I was also 22 when I started a real life down there You know you JB granddad went home put on the comfy socks and PJs and watch Rachel Maddow and learn my lines and went to bed Still doing the same thing today Over no regrets. What have you haven't missed anything. It's all going to be over. No regrets. What have you done? Nothing!|||你跟其他所有演员一起出去，然后你们玩得很开心……我开始在那边过上真实生活时也才22岁。你知道的，你那JB爷爷回家穿上舒适的袜子和睡衣，看着蕾切尔·玛多，背着台词就上床睡觉了。今天还在做同样的事。好了，毫无遗憾。你什么也没错过。这一切都将结束。毫无遗憾。你做了什么？什么都没做！
I've got one tooth left in my mouth. I've had no life experiences. But I'm thin! Yes! We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. Well, get off, I was like really, you know, I'm sure after this, I could talk about it forever.
I've got one tooth left in my mouth. I've had no life experiences. But I'm thin! Yes! We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. Well, get off, I was like really, you know, I'm sure after this, I could talk about it forever.|||我嘴里只剩一颗牙了。我没有任何人生经历。但我很瘦！耶！我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。好吧，别闹了，我真的……你知道的，我确信在这之后，我可以永远聊这个话题。
I love the show. No, shut up, you have not seen it. I love seeing every episode. The, was there anything, because it was like, at times it was really physical. And I remember Jason telling me that I was like, did you really do all that? He's like, no, that was a stunt double
I love the show. No, shut up, you have not seen it. I love seeing every episode. The, was there anything, because it was like, at times it was really physical. And I remember Jason telling me that I was like, did you really do all that? He's like, no, that was a stunt double|||我超爱这部剧。闭嘴吧你，你根本没看。我超爱看每一集。那个，有没有什么……因为有时候剧里真的有很多肢体动作。我记得詹森跟我说过，当时我就问：“你真的拍了所有那些动作吗？”他说：“不，那是替身演员——”
where he gets punched in the face, thrown on the floor, kicked across the like, did you really do all that? He's like, no, that was a stunt double where he gets punched in the face, thrown on the floor, kicked across the room. Did you have anything like that? Did you ever get hurt? Yeah, I mean, yeah. Yeah, but I'm also like, I'm like, you know. She's a little flower. Yeah, but I also don't sometimes carry myself like one.
where he gets punched in the face, thrown on the floor, kicked across the like, did you really do all that? He's like, no, that was a stunt double where he gets punched in the face, thrown on the floor, kicked across the room. Did you have anything like that? Did you ever get hurt? Yeah, I mean, yeah. Yeah, but I'm also like, I'm like, you know. She's a little flower. Yeah, but I also don't sometimes carry myself like one.|||被人打脸、摔在地板上、一脚踢飞 across the room……“你真的拍了所有那些动作吗？”他说：“不，那是替身演员挨拳打脚踢、被摔在地板上、在房间里被踢来踢去。”你也有过这样的经历吗？你受过伤吗？对，我是说，有啊。对，但我也属于那种……你知道的。她是一朵小花。对，但我有时行事风格可不像个娇滴滴的小花。
So that's how I get hurt. Oh, okay, okay. Julia, have you learned how to- Yes, I'm like, oh yeah, I'll be fine. I'll be fine. Have you learned how to drive since the show? You didn't know how to drive? This woman, I mean, you asked her to just drive 10 feet.
So that's how I get hurt. Oh, okay, okay. Julia, have you learned how to- Yes, I'm like, oh yeah, I'll be fine. I'll be fine. Have you learned how to drive since the show? You didn't know how to drive? This woman, I mean, you asked her to just drive 10 feet.|||所以这就是我受伤的原因。哦，好吧，好吧。朱莉娅，你学会……是的，我就那种“哦耶，我会没事的。我会没事的”。自从拍完这部剧，你学会开车了吗？你以前不会开车吗？这个女人，我是说，你只要让她开10英尺。
Just hit the mark. You just gave me a drive 10 feet. I'm going to learn how to drive. I promise. We're going to put sandbags in front of the wheel. And you're going to be the first person that I'm going to call. As soon as I learn how to drive.
Just hit the mark. You just gave me a drive 10 feet. I'm going to learn how to drive. I promise. We're going to put sandbags in front of the wheel. And you're going to be the first person that I'm going to call. As soon as I learn how to drive.|||只要开到那个指定位置就行。你刚才让我开10英尺。我一定会去学开车的。我保证。我们要在方向盘前面堆满沙袋。而你将成为我学会开车后第一个打电话的人。只要我一学会开车。
I'm not getting in the car. I will not get in the car to you. I think I'll be a great, I think. At least a year under your belt. Wait, Julie, do you drive now or you still don't drive? No, because I just, I've been. Where do you live? Los Angeles. Yeah.
I'm not getting in the car. I will not get in the car to you. I think I'll be a great, I think. At least a year under your belt. Wait, Julie, do you drive now or you still don't drive? No, and then whenever I'm in the process of learning how to drive, then I have to leave town. For real, like it's like always like that. So as soon as like learning how to drive, then I have to leave town. For real, it's always like that. So as soon as I want to work, I just try to learn how to drive and then I'll. So how do you get around?|||我是不会上车的。我是绝不会坐你开的车的。我觉得我会成为一个非常……我觉得。至少得让你练个一年再说。等等，朱莉娅，你现在会开车了还是依然不会开车？不会，而且每当我在学开车的过程中时，我就必须得离开这个镇子。真的，每次都这样。所以每当我刚开始学开车，我就得离开小镇。真的，一直都是这样。所以每当我想要去工作时，我就会试着学开车，然后我就……那你平时怎么出行？
Okay, well, I don't, I. You honestly still don't drive? No, and then whenever I'm in the process of learning how to drive, then I have to leave town. For real, like it's like always like that. So as soon as like learning how to drive, then I have to leave town. For real, it's always like that. So as soon as I want to work, I just try to learn how to drive and then I'll. So how do you get around?
You Uber all the time or does Mark drive you around? Both. Friends. You know what the kids say today? Yeah, what the kids say, I'm like a passenger princess. That's what the kids say today. Totally. By the way, even if I learn how to drive, I still love to be driven.|||你一直都坐 Uber 还是马克开车送你？两者都有。还有朋友。你知道现在的小孩怎么说吗？对，小孩们怎么说来着，我就像是个“副驾公主”。这就是现在的小孩的说法。完全是这样。顺便说一句，就算我学会了开车，我还是喜欢别人开车送我。
You Uber all the time or does Mark drive you around? Both. Friends. You know what the kids say today? Yeah, what the kids say, I'm like a passenger princess. That's what the kids say today. Totally. By the way, even if I learn how to drive, I still love to be driven.
I'm not going to lie. Like, I love it. Call me if you ever need a ride. I like to drive. All right, wait. Wait a minute, Julie. Wait, I want to stay on this driving thing just for just two seconds. Okay, okay, Sean.|||我实话实说。真的，我超喜欢这样。如果你需要搭车随时给我打电话。我喜欢开车。好吧，等等。等一下，朱莉娅。等等，我想在这个开车的话题上多停留两秒钟。好吧，好吧，肖恩。
I'm not going to lie. Like, I love it. Call me if you ever need a ride. I like to drive. All right, wait. Wait a minute, Julie. Wait, I want to stay on this driving thing just for just two seconds. Okay, okay, Sean.
So, wait, you have your friends drive you or Mark is your boyfriend or husband? I can ask you 70 million questions about this. Wait. And have you ever waymode? So, wait, you have your friends drive you, or I'm guessing Mark is your boyfriend or husband? Yeah, my husband. I could ask you 17 million questions about this. And have you ever waymode? Is that the thing that- is a self-driving car? That scares me. I don't like that. I've done that before with my friend,|||所以，等等，你是让朋友开车送你，还是马克是你的男友或老公？关于这个我可以问你七千万个问题。等等。而且你用过 Waymo 吗？所以，等等，你是让朋友开车送你，还是我猜马克是你的男友或老公？对，我老公。关于这个我可以问你一千七百万个问题。而且你用过 Waymo 吗？就是那种……自动驾驶汽车？那个吓到我了。我不喜欢那个。我以前和朋友一起坐过，
So, wait, you have your friends drive you or Mark is your boyfriend or husband? I can ask you 70 million questions about this. Wait. And have you ever waymode? So, wait, you have your friends drive you, or I'm guessing Mark is your boyfriend or husband? Yeah, my husband. I could ask you 17 million questions about this. And have you ever waymode? Is that the thing that's a self-driving car? That scares me. I don't like that. I've done that before with my friend,
because he also doesn't drive, because he's from the UK, and that scares me. That's crazy. Sean's a big advocate. Well, no, I mean, I think it's where the future is gonna I think ultimately like 20 Is that where we're going? Prognosticator yeah, do you think AI is gonna have an impact? Wait, what's AI? What's gonna be popular computers? What else?|||因为他也不会开车，他来自英国，那个真的很吓人。太疯狂了。肖恩是个坚定的拥护者。不，我是说，我觉得那是未来发展的方向……我觉得最终，比如20……这就是我们要去的地方吗？预言家，是吧？你觉得人工智能会产生影响吗？等等，什么是人工智能？什么会变得流行？计算机吗？还有呢？
because he also doesn't drive, because he's from the UK, and that scares me. That's crazy. Sean's a big advocate. Well, no, I mean, I think it's where the future is gonna I think ultimately like 20 Is that where we're going? Prognosticator yeah, do you think AI is gonna have an impact? Wait, what's AI? What's gonna be popular computers? What else?
I think food's really gonna catch on any more hot takes I think food's really gonna catch on. Any more hot takes? Julia, I've got a question for you. Sean, quiet please. Yes, Dave. So you booked Martha Marcy Mae Marlene. Yeah. Hold for applause.|||我觉得食物真的会大受欢迎。还有什么惊人之语吗？我觉得食物真的会大受欢迎。还有什么惊人之语吗？朱莉娅，我有个问题想问你。肖恩，请安静。好的，戴夫。所以你接了《双面玛莎》。对。掌声响起来。
I think food's really gonna catch on any more hot takes I think food's really gonna catch on. Any more hot takes? Julia, I've got a question for you. Sean, quiet please. Yes, Dave. So you booked Martha Marcy Mae Marlene. Yeah. Hold for applause.
At 16, was this the first time that you really felt acting was a viable career path, Julia? Julia, please answer the question. Please answer the question. Please answer the question. It was still like a test because I was so young. I was 16. So I was still in- That was like the first biggie, right? Yeah, that was the first job.|||在16岁时，这是你第一次真正觉得表演是一条可行的职业道路吗，朱莉娅？朱莉娅，请回答这个问题。请回答这个问题。请回答这个问题。这对我来说仍然像是一场测试，因为我当时太年轻了。我才16岁。所以我当时还在……那算是你的第一个大制作，对吧？对，那是我的第一份工作。
At 16, was this the first time that you really felt acting was a viable career path, Julia? Julia, please answer the question. Please answer the question. Please answer the question. It was still like a test because I was so young. I was 16. So I was still in- That was like the first biggie, right? Yeah, that was the first job.
And I didn't really know because this was 2010. And so Sundance was not what it is today. It wasn't like it was still felt kind of indie in that way. There was, I think like swag bag was like a thing for like two, it was like, it was just new. So it wasn't commercialized in a way. So I didn't really know what that, anything was. So it felt more like a test, I guess, in a way. But I just really loved it. I just|||我当时其实并不知道，因为那是2010年。所以当时的圣丹斯电影节可不是现在这个样子。它当时的感觉还是那种比较独立电影的风格。当时，我记得礼品袋才刚出现两年左右，那简直……那是个新鲜事物。所以它在某种程度上还没有商业化。因此我真的不知道那是什么，任何东西都不知道。所以我觉得在某种程度上它更像是一场测试。但我真的很喜欢它。我只是……
And I didn't even really know because this was 2010. And so Sundance was not what it is today. It wasn't like it was still felt kind of indie in that way. There was, I think like swag bag was like a thing for like two, it was like, it was just new. So it wasn't commercialized in a way. So I didn't really know what that, anything was. So it felt more like a test, I guess, in a way. But I just really loved it. I just
loved meeting people. And then Phil kind of took off and you started to get some notoriety and the phone started ringing just a little bit and like, was that kind of exciting? Notoriety? Was it bad news? What happened? Did you do something bad? Could you kind of see the future a little bit? Did you have the courage to kind of dream a little bit there or was it still a little bit? Did you have the courage to kind of dream a little bit there or was it still a little distant? Well, I've always been a big dreamer, but I never thought that my life would end up|||喜欢结识各种各样的人。然后影片差不多火了，你开始获得了一些名气，电话也开始多多少少响了起来，比如，那种感觉是不是挺令人兴奋的？名气？是坏消息吗？发生了什么？你做了什么坏事吗？你能稍微预见一下未来吗？你在那里有勇气稍微做做梦吗？还是说这依然有点……你在那里有勇气稍微做做梦吗？还是说这依然感觉有点遥远？嗯，我一直是个喜欢做大梦的人，但我从未想过我的人生会变成——
loved meeting people. And then Phil kind of took off and you started to get some notoriety and the phone started ringing just a little bit and like, was that kind of exciting? Notoriety? Was it bad news? What happened? Did you do something bad? Could you kind of see the future a little bit? Did you have the courage to kind of dream a little bit there or was it still a little bit? Did you have the courage to kind of dream a little bit there or was it still a little distant? Well, I've always been a big dreamer, but I never thought that my life would end up
like this. I never thought that this was... I always loved movies. I grew up watching Turner Classic movies and I always loved, loved films, but there was still something that felt very far, even though I grew up in New York and I grew up around actors and going to the theater, but there's something that felt very far because it wasn't, I didn't know it was like a real profession. Like, it didn't feel real. Right, so then even as sort of some momentum|||这样。我从没想过这会是……我一直很喜欢电影。我从小看特纳经典电影长大，我一直非常、非常热爱电影，但总觉得有些东西非常遥远，尽管我在纽约长大，身边都是演员，也经常去剧院，但总觉得有些东西非常遥远，因为这不是……我当时并不知道这是一份真正的职业。就像，感觉不那么真实。对，所以即使随着一些势头——
like this. I never thought that this was... I always loved movies. I grew up watching Turner Classic movies and I always loved, loved films, but there was still something that felt very far, even though I grew up in New York and I grew up around actors and going to the theater, but there's something that felt very far because it wasn't, I didn't know it was like a real profession. Like, it didn't feel real. Right, so then even as sort of some momentum
started to gain there, so you're 16, you're approaching the end of what would be the high school years and the possibility to maybe go to college and study another career. So since you weren't really committed to, you weren't allowing yourself to feel super positive about a career in the business, were you keeping your other irons hot|||开始在那边积聚，你当时16岁，正接近高中时期的尾声，面临着也许去上大学并学习另一项职业的可能性。既然你并没有全心投入，没有让自己对这个圈子里的职业生涯抱有超级乐观的态度，你有没有同时在物色其他备选的出路呢？
started to gain there, so you're 16, you're approaching the end of what would be the high school years and the possibility to maybe go to college and study another career. So since you weren't really committed to, you weren't allowing yourself to feel super positive about a career in the business, were you keeping your other irons hot
as far as other occupations, other industries? No, because I was so bad at everything else. And I seemed. She didn't, you were all in. You didn't even go to college? No, and I was like, oh well, I'm getting a good response with this, so I must be okay with it,|||比如其他职业、其他行业？没有，因为我在其他所有事情上都太糟糕了。而且我看起来……她没有，你完全是全力以赴。你甚至都没去上大学？没有，当时我就想：哦好吧，我在这方面得到了不错的反响，那我在这方面应该还行，
as far as other occupations, other industries? No, because I was so bad at everything else. And I seemed. She didn't, you were all in. You didn't even go to college? No, and I was like, oh well, I'm getting a good response with this, so I must be okay with it,
because I'm so bad at everything else. You know what's funny about that is that we, that's a common, that answer comes up for a lot and it goes for the three of us too, right? And what I find, I'm sort of coming to the conclusion that actors are just a bunch of people who are bad at everything else. Yeah.|||因为我在其他所有事情上都太糟糕了。关于这一点，有趣的是，我们……这是一个很常见的回答，很多人都会这么说，我们三个也是如此，对吧？我发现，我差不多得出了这样一个结论：演员其实就是一帮在其他所有事情上都很糟糕的人。对。
because I'm so bad at everything else. You know what's funny about that is that we, that's a common, that answer comes up for a lot and it goes for the three of us too, right? And what I find, I'm sort of coming to the conclusion that actors are just a bunch of people who are bad at everything else. Yeah.
All right, it's true. Let's pretend, let's get a job where we can pretend to be good at stuff. Yeah, it's kind of true. Yeah, that's so true. I didn't do, I don't do well when I feel like there's like, has to be rules in a way. Like I don't, I, you know, I like-|||好吧，确实如此。让我们假装……找一份我们可以假装自己很擅长某事的工作。对，有点道理。对，太对了。当我觉得有些地方……必须有规矩的时候，我往往表现得不太好。比如我不太……你知道的，我喜欢——
All right, it's true. Like let's pretend, let's get a job where we can pretend to be good at stuff. Yeah, it's kind of true. Yeah, that's so true. I didn't do, I don't do well when I feel like there's like, has to be rules in a way. Like I don't, I, you know, I like-
That there's a right way to do something and a wrong way to do something. Yeah, like I like running, I like the feeling of like running around and kind of being free, as corny as that sounds, but yeah. Right, right, right, right. Sounds like you're advocating for anarchy. Yeah, yeah.|||觉得做某事有正确的方法和错误的方法。对，比如我喜欢奔跑，我喜欢那种四处奔跑、感觉自己重获自由的感觉，听起来虽然有点老套，但确实如此。对，对，对，对。听起来你像是在鼓吹无政府主义。对，对。
That there's a right way to do something and a wrong way to do something. Yeah, like I like running, I like the feeling of like running around and kind of being free, as corny as that sounds, but yeah. Right, right, right, right. Sounds like you're advocating for anarchy. Yeah, yeah.
No, she is. She's a rule breaker. Yeah, I'm a rule breaker. I didn't know about this. I'm not against it. Tell me about, what is this David Chase thing that Wikipedia is talking about here? Oh, so there's actually, speaking of, so that was my second movie. This is Not Fade Away is Not Fade Away.|||不，她确实是。她是个不守规矩的人。对，我就是个不守规矩的人。我之前不知道这个。我不反对这个。跟我讲讲，维基百科上提到的这个大卫·蔡斯是怎么回事？哦，其实说到这个，那可以说是我的第二部电影。就是《迷失安迪沃霍尔》（Not Fade Away）。
No, she is. She's a rule breaker. Yeah, I'm a rule breaker. I didn't know about this. I'm not against it. Tell me about, what is this David Chase thing that Wikipedia is talking about here? Oh, so there's actually, speaking of, so that was my second movie. This is Not Fade Away is Not Fade Away.
Not Fade Away. And this is a crazy story. So my first time going to LA, I was, I just turned 17. It was like a month after I turned 17. And I only remember this because it was like in March and all the purple trees. I'd never seen anything like that.|||《迷失安迪沃霍尔》。这是一个疯狂的故事。我第一次去洛杉矶的时候，我……我刚满17岁。大约是我满17岁的一个月后。我之所以只记得这个，是因为那是三月份，到处都是紫色的树。我从来没见过那种景象。
Not Fade Away. And this is a crazy story. So my first time going to LA, I was, I just turned 17. It was like a month after I turned 17. And I only remember this because it was like in March and all the purple trees. I'd never seen anything like that.
Jackarandas. Jackarandas, yeah. Yeah. Jackarandas. Yeah, and I remember being Jackarandas. like in March and all the purple trees. I'd never seen anything like that in New York. Yeah. And I remember being, check it mom doll. Were you alone at 17 or did you come out with mom? No, I came out with mom and my acting coach. Oh yeah? You know, and.|||蓝花楹。蓝花楹，对。对。蓝花楹。对，我记得是蓝花楹。就像在三月，到处都是紫色的树。我在纽约从未见过那样的景象。对。我记得当时……查一下妈妈娃娃。你17岁时是独自一人，还是跟妈妈一起来的？不，我是跟妈妈还有我的表演教练一起来的。哦是吗？你知道的，然后……
Jackarandas. Jackarandas, yeah. Yeah. Jackarandas. Yeah, and I remember being Jackaranda. like in March and all the purple trees. I'd never seen anything like that in New York. Yeah. And I remember being, check it mom doll. Were you alone at 17 or did you come out with mom? No, I came out with mom and my acting coach. Oh yeah? You know, and.
Did you stay at the Oakwoods? Yeah. You did? Did you really? Nearby, yeah. And we didn't know where anything was. in the Oakwoods? Yeah. You did? Did you really? Nearby, yeah. Oh, I did. And we didn't know where anything was. This was like, GPS was new, so it was like recalculating.|||你们住在橡树园公寓吗？对。真的吗？真的吗？就在附近，对。而且我们根本不知道任何东西在哪儿。在橡树园公寓？对。真的吗？真的吗？就在附近，对。哦，我住过。而且我们根本不知道任何东西在哪儿。那时候……GPS 还是个新鲜事物，所以它总是在“正在重新规划路线”。
Did you stay at the Oakwoods? Yeah. You did? Did you really? Nearby, yeah. And we didn't know where anything was. in the Oakwoods? Yeah. You did? Did you really? Nearby, yeah. Oh, I did. And we didn't know where anything was. This was like, GPS was new, so it was like recalculating.
It was like all the time. It was so crazy. Sounds like mom was as gifted as you are behind the wheel. Yeah, basically. Yes, recalculating, exactly. But it was one of those times that I had crazy callbacks, auditions every single day while I was doing that one day of shoot for the David Chase project|||基本上无时无刻不在重新规划。太疯狂了。听起来你妈妈在开车这方面跟你一样很有天赋。对，基本上是这样。没错，“正在重新规划路线”，完全如此。但那是那种我疯狂接到复试通知的时期之一，我一边为大卫·蔡斯的项目进行为期一天的拍摄，一边每天都要去试镜。
It was like all the time. It was so crazy. Sounds like mom was as gifted as you are behind the wheel. Yeah, basically. Yes, recalculating, exactly. But it was one of those things that I had crazy callbacks, auditions every single day while I was doing that one day of shoot for the David Chase project
that he basically wrote that part for me because I auditioned for a different part. And I didn't get James Gadolfini's daughter, so he wrote, he was like, I wrote a part for you, and it was like in this dream sequence. So that was my first time in LA. And on the plane, I got the worst eye infection on my way there.|||他基本上是专门为我写了那个角色，因为我当时试镜的是另一个角色。我没能演成詹姆斯·加尔多芬尼的女儿，于是他写道……他说：“我为你写了一个角色”，大概是在一个梦境序列里。所以那是我的第一次洛杉矶之行。而在飞往那里的飞机上，我得了这辈子最严重的眼部感染。
that he basically wrote that part for me because I auditioned for a different part. And I didn't get James Gadolfini's daughter, so he wrote, he was like, I wrote a part for you, and it was like in this dream sequence. So that was my first time in LA. And on the plane, I got the worst eye infection on my way there.
I had green pus coming out of my eye, like green goo. It was terrible. And I had all these auditions booked, all these callbacks. Like sometimes, these callbacks, I was looking at them, I'm like, where are these meetings now? Like, I'm like, these meetings were crazy. And I had- Oh, you poor thing, you must have been just a nervous wreck|||我的眼睛里流出了绿色的脓液，就像绿色的黏液一样。太可怕了。而且我预约了所有这些试镜、所有这些复试。有时候，看着这些复试通知，我就想：这些会面现在都在哪儿呢？就像，我觉得这些会面太疯狂了。我当时……哦，你这个可怜的孩子，你当时肯定紧张得快崩溃了。
I had green pus coming out of my eye, like green goo. It was terrible. And I had all these auditions booked, all these callbacks. Like sometimes, these callbacks, I was looking at them, I'm like, where are these meetings now? Like, I'm like, these meetings were crazy. And I had- Oh, you poor thing, you must have been just a nervous wreck
我的眼睛流出了绿色的脓液，就像绿色的黏液一样。太可怕了。我当时有很多试镜预约，还有很多复试。有时候，看着这些复试，我在想，这些会面现在在哪里？我就觉得，这些会面太疯狂了。而且我——哦，你这个可怜的小家伙，你当时一定急得像热锅上的蚂蚁吧。
that you were gonna show up with this pink eye. So this callback, this callback that I had, so there was all these callbacks and auditions and meetings with this like, and it wasn't contagious. So I went to a doctor and they're like, yeah, you're fine, but it just looks, it's literally an eye sore. And I got this phone call, well, I had a chemistry read with claredanes.
你竟然顶着个红眼病就来了。所以这场试戏，我当时经历了好几轮试戏、面试，和这样一个……而且它不是传染性的。所以我去看过医生，他们说，没事，但看起来确实挺碍眼的。然后我接到了电话，哦，我和克莱尔·丹尼斯有一场对手戏试读。
So I had to like go in with an eye infection with claredanes, and I had to apologize, basically explain my eye, which was horrific. Don't look at this one, look at this one. Yeah. That so-called eye. And then... Well, that is great.
所以我顶着个眼部感染去见克莱尔·丹尼斯，我不得不道歉，基本上解释了一下我的眼睛，那太可怕了。别看这只，看这只。对，那只所谓的眼睛。然后……嗯，那真的很棒。
And then in the middle of all these meetings, going back and forth, didn't know where I was going, never been to LA, I got a call from my manager all these meetings going back and forth, didn't know where I was going, never been to LA. I got a call from my manager and a few weeks before I went out, in New York I went on this audition for an untitled Paul Thomas Anderson film. Is there a phone ringing? I can't... No, you made a movie. I don't know what's going on. I didn't see that one.
然后在一堆来回奔波的面试中间，我晕头转向的，从来没去过洛杉矶，我接到了经纪人的电话——在一堆来回奔波的面试中间，我晕头转向的，从来没去过洛杉矶，我接到了经纪人的电话。就在我出发去纽约的前几周，我去试镜了一个保罗·托马斯·安德森的未定名电影。是有电话在响吗？我不能……不，你拍了部电影。我不知道怎么回事。我没看过那部。
Yeah. By the way, it would be a great title for a Paul Thomas Anderson film. Is there a phone ringing? Exactly. No, so it was an untitled Paul Thomas Anderson film. I was 16 and they called in. They're like, he wants to meet with you. So I had that. and they called in, they're like, he wants to meet with you. So I had that, and then it turned out to be for the master.
对。顺便说一句，这名字当保罗·托马斯·安德森的电影名挺不错的。是有电话在响吗？没错。不，所以那是一部保罗·托马斯·安德森的未定名电影。我当时16岁，他们打电话来，说：“他想见你。”所以我有了那次机会，他们打电话来，说：“他想见你。”所以我有了那次机会，结果发现那是为《大师》准备的。
Oh wow, I love that. Yeah, and, but I had this eye infection. Like I had this crazy chemistry read. And yeah, but that was my first time in LA. And then also who I met that week was Fred Roos. I was 17 years old. It was like one of, you know, he was the producer of The Godfather. But then by then I met him,
哦哇，我太喜欢那个了。对，而且，我当时眼睛感染了。就像我经历了一场疯狂的默契度试读。对，但那是我第一次去洛杉矶。然后那周我还见到了弗雷德·鲁斯。我当时17岁。就像是，你知道的，他是《教父》的制片人。但到我见到他的时候，
it was like a Friday in my eye, like calm down. But during that time I also did not fade away, just to give you, you know, I'm giving you the bullet points. What were you meeting with Fred Roos about? Just a general meeting, I guess, I don't know. It was kind of- Did he make you an offer you couldn't refuse? Hell no!
就像是一个星期五，我的眼睛，真想冷静点。但那段时间我也没有淡出，为了让你了解，（你知道的）我只挑重点说。你和弗雷德·鲁斯见面是为了什么？就是个例行见面吧，我不知道。有点像——他有没有给你一个无法拒绝的提议？去他的！
No, I just met with him. Okay, I just thought maybe, yeah. So jump from that to... Yeah, but that was my first time in LA. Like crazy trip. So if you will, make a big huge leap now from your sort of nascent stage there, and now you've just won your first Emmy
不，我只是和他见了个面。好吧，我以为可能……是的。所以从那直接跳到……对，但那是我第一次去洛杉矶。简直是疯狂的旅程。所以，如果你愿意的话，现在来个超级大跳跃，从你当时刚崭露头角的阶段，直接跳到你刚刚赢得第一个艾美奖——
of three consecutive Emmys, by the way. Unbelievable. What did that feel? So you've just won an Emmy. What a streak! What a streak! Been beaten three years in a row! What was that like?
顺便说一句，是连续三座艾美奖的第一座。难以置信。那种感觉是什么样的？所以你刚刚赢得了艾美奖。多棒的连胜纪录！多棒的连胜纪录！连续三年获奖！那种感觉是怎样的？
Personally and professionally, was there a big sea change or was it sort of a gradual thing? Or, sorry, I'm recalling that. Here's the question. Did the next day after winning an Emmy feel like you thought it would when you allowed yourself to dream back when you were a little kid? Very good, very good.
在个人和职业上，这是一个巨大的巨变，还是一个渐进的过程？或者，抱负，我在回忆这个。问题是这样的：当你允许自己在小时候做白日梦时，得奖后的第二天，感觉会像你想象的那样吗？非常好，非常好。
Well, first of all, Jason, I just want to say like the, it's, you know, it was such a dream working with you this whole time, or that whole time of just the, and what I mean is like the process, it really, the next day, it was not depressing, it was not depressing, but it made you look at how important the process is and the experience rather than the result in a way.
嗯，首先，杰森，我只想说，这，你知道的，这段时间或者整个过程中能和你一起合作简直像个梦想，我的意思是整个过程，真的，第二天，它并没有让人沮丧，它并不让人沮丧，但它让你看到相比于结果，过程和经历其实是多么重要。
And it's a token in a way. It's an amazing token and it's like an opportunity for things, but then after the opportunity, you're looking for a new process in a way. Yeah, because you kind of feel like there's nothing really changed. It's just the next day. Well, the dwarf in Russia and all that stuff
它在某种程度上是一个纪念品。这是一个了不起的纪念品，也是一个带来机遇的契机，但在机遇之后，你其实是在寻找一个新的过程。对，因为你会觉得好像什么都没有真正改变。这只是普通的一天。嗯，在俄罗斯的那个小矮人还有那些乱七八糟的，
is all in the anticipation. It's not in the getting of the thing, which is true. Yeah, and also your problems, like you'll have 30 seconds up there, and it's great, and then you get off the stage and then you're like the next day your problems are, personally your problems are still following you. It doesn't change anything.
全都在于期待之中。不在于得到那个东西的那一刻，确实如此。是的，而且你的问题，你在领奖台上只有30秒，这很棒，然后你走下舞台，第二天你的问题是——从个人角度来说，你的问题依然在纠缠着你。它什么也没有改变。
That's why I've never won an Emmy. That's why. You just keep returning. Yeah, no, I want to take myself out of the running. It's not going to change anything. Yeah, I know you mean it. But it's funny, I think what it resulted to was after that, I was, it made me feel not confident
这就是为什么我从来没得过艾美奖。这就是原因。你只是不断回归。对，不，我想把自己排除在候选之外。这改变不了任何事。对，我知道你是认真的。但很有趣，我觉得它带来的结果是，之后我感到了一种完全不同的、没有自信的状态，
in a complete different way, in a sense. Because what it does, well, when you have a win after win after win after win, you kind of put this pressure or you feel like people are having this expectation on you. But during the strike, I went to clown school, because I didn't know what else to do with my time. And I went to France, and the thing that the teacher, Philippe Golié, who's amazing, he kept on saying, you know the...
从某种意义上来说。因为它的作用是，当你连续不断地赢赢赢赢时，你多少会背上这种压力，或者觉得人们对你抱有这种期望。但在罢工期间，我去上了小丑学校，因为我不知道该把时间花在什么上面。我去了法国，我的老师菲利普·加利耶（Philippe Golié）是个了不起的人，他一直挂在嘴边的一句话是，你知道……
Screw that son of a bitch. I'll show this guy a thing or two about being a clown. Oh, you like French? Come to Italy. Sorry, this is a running joke. He's got a real loud mouth. He's a handful in the back of the ear. And he's got a real touchy incentive about other Europeans. Yes, exactly.
见鬼去吧，那个混蛋。我要让这家伙见识一下当小丑是怎么回事。哦，你喜欢法国？来意大利吧。抱歉，这是个老笑话。他的嗓门可真大。在后排简直是个让人头疼的家伙。而且他对其他欧洲人有着一种极度敏感的自尊心。是的，没错。
But he kept on saying the failure is the friend of the clown, which I love. Failure is the friend of the clown. I like that. And you can't have great art if you don't have some sort of like, you know, humility in a way. Please tell me what goes on in clown school. A lot of things. Face painting.
但他一直说，失败是小丑的朋友，我太喜欢这句话了。失败是小丑的朋友。我喜欢这个。而且如果你没有某种类似，你知道的，谦逊的品质，你就无法创作出伟大的艺术。请告诉我小丑学校里都发生些什么。很多事情。面部彩绘。
But I mean like you hear that. Are you guys kind of juggling a lot of different things? Yeah. Nice Will, another nice one. Well actually I didn't, you know I didn't, I did get a clown certificate so you are talking to a certified clown. Was it an oversized shoe or?
但我的意思是，你听到了。你们是在抛接很多不同的东西吗？对。威尔，说得好，又是一个好梗。其实我没有，你知道我没有，我确实拿到了一个小丑证书，所以你现在是在和一个持证小丑讲话。是一双超大的鞋子还是？
Or just a red nose. Did it pull me? It was a red nose and he assigned me, he took one look at me and he was like, you are the witch. He assigned me to be a witch. I don't know, I maybe give him like witch energy. The witch with one cigarette.
还是只有一个红鼻子？它吸引到我了吗？那是一个红鼻子，他看了我一眼就给我定了性，他说：“你就是那个女巫。”他分配我演一个女巫。我不知道，我可能散发着某种女巫的气场吧。叼着一支烟的女巫。
Wait, but I mean, do you do like, cause I hear it and I'm an idiot, so I hear, I went to clown school and I do everything that Jason and Will are joking about. Like I think about like, oh, well you put the paint, is it that, you paint your face and you put on white? No, no, it's. It's old school like European clown.
等等，但我的意思是，你们是在做那种，因为我听人说过，而且我是个白痴，所以我听说——我去上了小丑学校，然后我做了所有杰森和威尔在开玩笑的事情。就像我在想，哦，你涂上油漆，是那种吗，你在脸上涂彩绘然后戴上白色的？不，不，那是。那是老派的欧洲小丑。
Yeah, it's old school, yeah. It's kind of depressing. Oh really? Yeah, it's like he puts you on stage and then you go behind a curtain and then they cue the music and you walk around like in a clown circle and then you just, and then you go behind a curtain and then they cue the music and you walk around like in a clown circle and then you just, and then the music stops and you just have to do whatever comes to your mind
对，是老派的，对。有点令人沮丧。哦，真的吗？对，就像他把你放在舞台上，然后你走到幕布后面，接着他们播放音乐，你在一个小丑圈里走来走去，然后你只需，然后你走到幕布后面，他们播放音乐，你在一个小丑圈里走来走去，然后你只需，然后音乐停了，你必须做出任何脑海中闪过的动作，
and make people laugh. And if you don't make people laugh, he kicks you off the stage. Oh my God, wow. So you have to really kind of just completely almost humiliate yourself. Just basically pull your pants down metaphorically, right? And just be a fool.
然后逗大家笑。如果你没能逗笑大家，他就会把你赶下舞台。天哪，哇。所以你真的必须在某种程度上完全、几乎是当众羞辱自己。基本上就是字面意义上的脱下裤子，对吧？然后当个傻瓜。
Be a fool. So I also, I just felt this, the first two days, I was like, what the fuck am I doing? Why did I do this? What is wrong with me? I'm not even a Paris, I'm in this town, which by the way, the town that I was staying in, I was like, why is this energy so crazy?
当个傻瓜。所以我也，我只是有这种感觉，前两天，我在想：我他妈在干什么？我为什么要这么做？我有什么毛病？我甚至不是巴黎人，我待在这个镇上——顺便说一句，我住的那个小镇，我在想：为什么这里的气场这么疯狂？
And there's the biggest mental asylum in France the town that I was staying in, I was like, sign me up for like the weirdest experience and I'm like all up for that. But yeah, no, it was an amazing, it was a 10 out of 10 experience, genuinely, it was amazing. How about that? Yeah, that's really cool. So has it adjusted your acting at all?
法国最大的精神病院就在那个镇上。我当时就在想：给我报名体验最诡异的经历吧，我完全奉陪。但说真的，这真是一次了不起的经历，绝对是10分满分的体验，真的太棒了。怎么样？对，这真的很酷。那这有没有对你的演技产生任何调整？
Did it sort of incorporate this fearlessness of humiliation? Although you were always brave about, you never worried about making yourself look foolish or ugly or flawed or something like that. No, not ugly. Well, no, and I think for me it was more that I just needed to, I have to constantly make myself feel uncomfortable.
它是否融入了这种无所畏惧的羞辱感？尽管你一直都很勇敢，从不担心让自己看起来很傻、很丑、有缺陷或诸如此类的事情。不，不是丑。好吧，不，我觉得对我的意义更多在于我需要，我必须不断让自己感到不舒服。
And that's gonna make me feel comfortable as an artist. Like, if I feel any sort of comfortability, I don't, like, then something's deeply wrong. Yeah, I totally get it. And also, I don't like... You totally get it. You're comfortable beyond me. Are you serious? No, no, I know, the being uncomfortable.
这才会让我作为一名艺术家感到舒适。如果我感到哪怕一丝一毫的舒适感，我不行，那说明情况肯定出了严重的问题。对，我完全懂。而且我不喜欢……你完全懂。你舒适得远超常人。你是认真的吗？不，不，我知道，那种不舒服的感觉。
You walk around in cashier slippers starting at 10.30 a.m. You and one other person living in a 15,000 square foot house. Shut the hell up, Sean. Go ahead, Cass. I'm uncomfortable. She's talking about discomfort as a fucking artist. Jesus Christ. I'm not talking, listen, don't give me, I love my sweaters, but I just. There's our bumper sticker. We'll be right back.
你大早上10点半穿着收银员的拖鞋到处走。你和另外一个人住在1.5万平方英尺的房子里。闭上你他妈的嘴，肖恩。说吧，卡斯。我很不舒服。她居然在谈论作为他妈的艺术家的不适感。天呐。我不是在说，听着，别跟我来这套，我喜欢我的毛衣，但我只是……这就是我们的汽车贴纸。我们马上回来。
All right, back to the show. Julia, now, you're surrounded by musicals that are not really your thing. I mean, I'm not saying that you're not, Right back. Alright, back to the show. Julia, now you're surrounded by musical instruments, and I've been wanting to ask since, are these yours? No, these are my husband's. Okay. We're setting up a studio here.
好了，回到节目中。朱莉，现在，你被那些其实并不太对你胃口的乐器包围了。我的意思是，我不是说你没有……马上回来。好了，回到节目中。朱莉，现在你被各种乐器包围了，我一直想问，从刚才起，这些是你的吗？不，这些是我丈夫的。好吧。我们在这里搭建了一个工作室。
She's married to a rock star, you stupid dick. Okay, nobody's supposed to know. No, I can't play anything. You're supposed to study up. What did you Google out during this interview? I didn't know it was... Is he a singer? I don't know who he... Forgive me.
她嫁给了一个摇滚巨星，你这个大笨蛋。好吧，本来没人应该知道的。不，我什么都不会弹。你应该提前做点功课的。你在这次采访中到底用谷歌搜了什么？我不知道那是……他是歌手吗？我不知道他是谁……原谅我。
He's Mark Foster, Foster the People. Oh, wonderful. I didn't know that. No, that's a band. This is a fantastic band. That's great. Wait, can I jump ahead? I mean, I'll let Jay drive it in a second,
他是马克·福斯特（Mark Foster），来自“福斯特之人群”（Foster the People乐队）。哦，太棒了。我不知道。不，那是个乐队。这是一个非常棒的乐队。太棒了。等等，我能插个话吗？我的意思是，我一会儿让杰伊来掌控，
but were you, I just remembered, were you supposed to play Madonna at some point? Is that gonna still happen? Yeah, I mean, that's supposed to still happen, but. That's wild. Yeah. What do you think, I mean, how did that come about? And like, were you ever a fan and all that?
但你是不是，我突然想起来，你之前是不是要在某个时候扮演麦当娜？那个项目还在进行吗？对，我的意思是，那个项目按计划应该还在进行，不过……太疯狂了。对。你觉得，我的意思是，那是怎么谈成的？还有，你以前是粉丝吗之类的？
Oh my God, I was such a fan of Madonna's. I grew up listening to Madonna. It just came about, I knew that they were doing a project, making a movie about it, and then I went out to audition. That was also another thing that I kind of just wanted to see if I could do it. Because, you know, I wasn't a trained dancer, and I had to like learn how to dance and then dance in front of her.
天哪，我超级崇拜麦当娜。我是听着麦当娜的歌长大的。事情的起因是，我知道他们在筹备一个项目，要拍一部关于她的电影，然后我就去试镜了。这也是另一件我只是想看看自己能不能做到的事。因为，你知道，我不是受过专业训练的舞者，我必须先学会跳舞，然后当着她的面跳舞。
And convince her that I can dance, basically. And sing. And sing with her. Wow. Stressful. Yeah. I mean, was... so then how was that? Did it go well? Did she give you a bunch of notes?
基本上要说服她我能跳舞。还要唱歌。和她一起合唱。哇。压力山大。对。我是说，当时……那感觉怎么样？进展顺利吗？她给了你一堆意见吗？
Or was she just like, oh my God, you're amazing, do this, do that? Well, you know, I kind of just like thought like, okay, what would Madonna do? Which is like, convince you that she deserved, you know, to be in this room. Right. And, you know. You owned it.
还是她直接说：“哦天哪，你太棒了，做这个，做那个？”嗯，你知道，我当时基本上就在想：好吧，麦当娜会怎么做？那就是——说服他们相信她有资格，你知道的，留在里屋。没错。而且，你知道。你Hold住了全场。
And I owned it. And I was kind of like, you can take it or leave it, but if you leave it, if I leave, then that's on you. You know what I mean? And it's like, if you take it, great. That kind of like mentality. Yeah, you just build that sexy indifference. And work the room, literally work the room.
我Hold住了全场。我当时的心态大概是：爱要不要，但如果你不要，如果我离开了，那是你的损失。你知道我的意思吗？这就好比：如果你接受了，太好了。就是这种心态。对，你得建立起那种性感的冷漠感。然后在房间里游刃有余，字面意义上的在房间里游刃有余。
So what happened with that? What happened with that? Still sort of brewing. Still brewing. It's a long gestating, you know, good meals take a long time. But I also feel like anything that's great also too, I notice if you hear stories,
那后来怎么样了？那后来怎么样了？还在酝酿中。还在酝酿。这是一个酝酿很久的项目，你知道，好饭不怕晚。但我也觉得任何伟大的事情也是如此，我发现如果你听那些故事，
like I feel like it takes a long time. Or it's, you know, it's either long or short. But meanwhile, meanwhile, you've snuck in a couple of fantastic jobs. Fantastic Four, anyone? Oh yes. July 25th. That's gonna be huge.
我觉得都需要很长的时间。或者说，要么长，要么短。但与此同时，与此同时，你悄悄接了几份了不起的工作。《神奇四侠》，有人知道吗？哦，是的。7月25日。那绝对是个重磅大作。
Yeah, I mean, what was that process like? I imagine there was a lot of effects. You had to work with that pain in the ass Pedro Pascal. I don't know how you get through that. How do you get through something like that? He's real chatty. It's so, I love him. You know, it's so funny,
对，我的意思是，那个过程是怎样的？我猜有很多特效。你还得和那个讨厌鬼佩德罗·帕斯卡（Pedro Pascal）合作。我不知道你是怎么忍受他的。你怎么能熬过那样的合作？他可真健谈。真的太，我太爱他了。你知道，太搞笑了，
because I met Pedro when I was 18. And everybody now is on this Pedro craze, which I'm so happy about, but I've... Not us. We're not fans, we're not fans. But I, you know, I've met him, and I always thought, you know, he was just so talented, and it was always a matter of time with him, I felt. And so, but what about, so like green screens
因为我18岁就认识佩德罗了。现在每个人都陷入了对佩德罗的狂热中，我为此感到由衷的高兴，但我……我们可没有。我们不是粉丝，我们不是粉丝。但，你知道的，我认识他，我一直觉得，你知道，他就是那么有才华，我觉得他大红大紫只是时间问题。所以，但是呢，绿幕
and special effects and all that, like that's a big spicy meatball, that thing. You've got costumes and like future stuff. What was that like? Well, no, I didn't have any costumes because they, I was just like with. Because you're a silver surfer. Yeah, so I was just like.
还有特效以及所有这些东西，那可真是个棘手的大麻烦。你得穿紧身衣还有搞未来科技的东西。那是种什么体验？噢，不，我没有穿任何紧身衣，因为我，我只是和……因为你是银影侠。对，所以我就……
Oh wait, you're the silver surfer? Yeah, so I was like. Take it easy, Sean. Yeah, so I was just like... Oh wait, you're the silver surfer? Yeah, so I was like... Take it easy, Sean. Yeah, so it was... There comes Scottie. Scottie's gonna slide in on a chair like Weekend Update. Hey, question! No, I used to love this.
等一下，你是银影侠？对，所以我就……放轻松，肖恩。对，所以那就是……斯蒂芬来啦。斯蒂芬要像《周末夜现场》那样坐着椅子滑进来了。嘿，有个问题！不，我以前超喜欢这个。
When I was a kid, I used to watch it all the time. Yeah, so just like I'm chrome and silver. Yeah, it's so cool. So does that mean you had to wear a green bodysuit with little markers on it for visual effects? I had the helmet with the giant GoPro-type camera and the wires. And it was crazy. And the first day on set, my first day on set was wild because, well, I finished Weapons,
我小时候经常看这个。对，所以我浑身镀铬，全是银色的。对，太酷了。那是不是意味着你得穿一件带有动作捕捉标记的绿色紧身衣来做视觉特效？我戴着那个装有类似巨型GoPro相机的头盔和电线。太疯狂了。而且我在片场的第一天，我在片场的第一天简直疯狂，因为，嗯，我刚拍完《武器》，
which is another thing. No, Weapons, let's not jump to the Josh Brolin vehicle coming out August 8th called Weapons. Yeah, by the way. So I filmed that like, I want to say like three weeks before, so like, but my first day on Fantastic, I... That's Fantastic Four, yeah. Fantastic Four, my first step, yes. Yes, that's Fantastic Four.
那是另一部作品。不，《武器》，我们先别急着提8月8日上映的乔什·布洛林主演的电影《武器》。对，顺便提一下。所以我大概在——我想大概是三周前拍完的，所以，但是我在《神奇》片场的头一天……那是《神奇四侠》，对。《神奇四侠》，我的第一场戏，是的。是的，那是《神奇四侠》。
I had to do this, like all these lines in the middle of, it's supposed to be like Times Square, and it was 30 feet in the air. JB, you did a bunch of lines in the middle of Times Square, right, like 94? Sure did, yeah. The New Year's celebration is always classic. That's what it was.
我必须得拍这个，在一群人中间说一堆台词，那场景本该是时代广场，而我当时在30英尺的高空中。JB，你曾在时代广场中间说过一堆台词，对吧，大概在94年？当然有，是的。跨年庆祝活动总是很经典。就是那样的。
But it was crazy because I was doing, it was my first day on set and I was doing a scene 30 feet in the air with an earpiece and a microphone, talking to 500 extras. And number two was at Marvel, from Marvel, was on set. So I was like, that was my first day. But after that I felt like I have no reason to be nervous, I think, if I can do a scene 33 in the air. You have a robust promotion schedule coming up.
但太疯狂了，因为我在演，那是我在片场的第一天，在30英尺的高空中拍一场戏，戴着耳机和麦克风，对着500名群众演员说话。而且漫威的二号人物，来自漫威的高管，当时就在片场。所以我当时想，那是我的第一天。但经历过那个之后，我觉得我没有任何理由再紧张了，我想，如果我能在33英尺的高空中演一场戏的话。你接下来有繁重的宣传日程。
You gonna travel the world for that? Yeah, so it's, I mean, I feel like with that, they were so, the four, the fantastic four, the cast, they were so nice and I kind of felt like a really nice dinner guest in a way. So they were really great hosts. So I'll come in and out to their dinners, but I'm not going to...
你要为此环游世界吗？对，所以，我的意思是，我觉得对于这个，他们人太好了，《神奇四侠》的演员们，他们人超级好，我感觉自己就像是一个非常讨人喜欢的晚宴客人。所以他们是非常棒的主人。我会去参加他们的晚宴，但我不会……
And I'll be a good dinner guest, but I'm not going to be the dinner guest. You'll be number five over there. You'll hit your cities. Exactly. Alright, so then that comes out July 25th and you got Weapons with Josh Brolin, August 8th. Jeez, man. Exactly. All right. So then that so then that comes out July 25th and you got weapons with Josh Brolin August 8 He's me. Tell what's what's weapons about first of all Brolin? I mean, yeah, bro
我会是一个优秀的晚宴客人，但我不会喧宾夺主。你在那边排第五位。你会去到各个城市的。没错。好吧，所以那部电影在7月25日上映，然后你还有和乔什·布洛林合作的《武器》，8月8日上映。天哪，老兄。没错。好吧。所以那部电影在7月25日上映，然后你还有和乔什·布洛林合作的《武器》，8月8日上映。真烦人。先说说《武器》是讲什么的，布洛林？我是说，对，布洛。
Now you think Pedro Pascal's a pain in the ass. Yeah, bro I know I just I work with all the bus men Jason Pedro Josh Well, you know how to slay the dragons. Yeah What is that one about? It's so crazy. It's kind of like a multi-story, intertwined spider web,
现在你觉得佩德罗·帕斯卡是个讨厌鬼了。对，布洛，我知道，我只是——我跟所有的硬汉都合作过，杰森、佩德罗、乔什。好吧，你可真懂得斩妖除魔。对，那部电影讲的是什么？太疯狂了。有点像多条故事线交织在一起的蜘蛛网，
but it's like a horror, magnolia kind of vibe. I don't even know how to explain it. I'm going to explain it. When all but one child from the same class mysteriously vanished on the same night at exactly the same time, a community is left questioning who or what is behind their disappearance.
但它是一种恐怖片，带点《木兰花》那种风格。我甚至不知道该怎么解释。我来解释一下吧。当一个班级里除了一个孩子之外的所有学生都在同一个夜晚、同一分、同一秒神秘失踪时，整个社区开始质疑究竟是谁或是什么东西在背后操纵着他们的消失。
Huh. Well there it is. And I play a teacher. I'm in. I'm in. I like you and I like the Brolin fella. I think he's going to go far. Julie, what do you do for fun?
哦。好吧，就是这样。我在里面演一个老师。算我一个。算我一个。我喜欢你，我也喜欢布洛林老弟。我觉得他前途无量。朱莉，你平时都做些什么来消遣？
Yeah, work, work, work, work, work. What do you do when you don't work. Julie, what do you do for fun? What do you do for fun? Yeah, work, work, work, work, work. What do you do when you don't work? Yeah, what do you do when you don't work? You sound like you work a lot, which is great, bravo. You know, it's great. Great work, Epic! But what do you do when you're just chilling? You're not driving, so we know that.
对，工作，工作，工作，工作，工作。不工作的时候你都做些什么。朱莉，你平时都做些什么来消遣？你平时都做些什么来消遣？对，不工作的时候你都做些什么？对，不工作的时候你都做些什么？听起来你工作排得很满，这很棒，太棒了。你知道，这很好。干得漂亮，史诗级！但当你只是在放松的时候，你会做些什么？你不会开车，所以我们知道这个。
Yeah. Are you...? What are the hobbies? I'm going to sound so bad in this interview. Oh my God. She just skateboards around LA. What's the hobby? Yeah.
对。你在……有什么爱好吗？在这个采访里我听起来太糟糕了。天哪。她只是在洛杉矶到处玩滑板。有什么爱好？对。
I'm trying to figure that out. You have zero hobby right now. But when you're down, like you're in LA, you're down, you've got down time. Well the problem is is that when I'm not working, I love watching movies, but then even then, it still feels like I'm reminded that it still worked. Like what are you gonna do the rest of today?
我正在努力想呢。你现在可以说是零爱好。但当你闲下来的时候，比如你在洛杉矶，你闲下来了，你有空闲时间。问题是，当我不工作的时候，我喜欢看电影，但即便如此，我还是会觉得自己是在提醒自己这依然是在工作。那你今天剩下的时间打算干什么？
You're not going to set today? Well, I have an ADR after this today. And then I am leaving on Thursday to Vancouver for five and a half months. Oh my God. Wow. So then you're gonna pack, you'll pack tomorrow. Yeah, yeah.
你今天不用去片场吗？嗯，今天这个之后我有一个ADR（后期对白配音）。然后我周四要出发去温哥华，待上五个半月。天哪。哇。所以你要收拾行李，你明天得收拾行李。对，对。
Right. Okay. So I'm always going to pack, you'll pack tomorrow. Yeah, yeah. Right, okay. It's not always working. That's great. What about, what are you watching right now on television? Aside from the movies. Like, will you just put on an old movie wherever it is? Yeah, well, and then, or I'll watch new stuff, or I'll watch things that, you know,
没错。好的。所以我总是要收拾行李，你明天得收拾行李。对，对。没错，好的。并不总是只有工作。那挺棒的。话说，你现在电视上都在看什么？除了电影之外。比如，你会随便找部老电影放着看吗？对，嗯，要么就是，我会看一些新的内容，或者我会看那些，你知道，
that I know that I should watch, that I haven't watched yet. Like Below Deck Mediterranean? Yeah, by the way, I never got into that. I'm maybe one of the few. But now I just, I'm gonna finish watching the Paul Rubin doc. It's really good. Oh yeah, I finished it. It's really good, it's interesting.
我知道我应该看但一直还没看的内容。比如《地中海下水道》？对，顺便说一句，我从来没入坑过那个。我可能是极少数没看过的。但现在我只是，我快要看完保罗·鲁宾斯（Paul Reubens）的纪录片了。真的很好看。哦，对，我刚看完。真的很好看，很有意思。
It's so good. Did you see the Osama Bin Laden doc? I started watching it and I wanted to binge watch it, so I stopped. But it looks, it's interesting. It's so good. Did you see the Osama Bin Laden dog? I started watching it and I wanted to binge watch it, so I stopped, but it looks, it's amazing. Now what about, talk to me about fashion and modeling, I'm sure that's a passion for you, but also fun. Well, I mean, I kind of. Sorry, not for you, this is for our guest,
太好看了。你看过本·拉登的纪录片吗？我开始看了，而且我恨不得一口气看完，所以我暂停了。但看起来，它很有意思。太好看了。你看过本·拉登的纪录片吗？我开始看了，而且我恨不得一口气看完，所以我暂停了，但看起来，它太棒了。那关于时尚和模特，跟我聊聊这个，我确信这对你来说是种热情所在，但也是一种乐趣。好吧，我的意思是，我有点……抱歉，不是对你说的，这是对我们的嘉宾说的，
this is for our guest, Julia. Yeah, yeah. Is that kind of a hobby? I mean, you don't look at it as, you're not doing that to make a living because you make plenty as an actor. I'd imagine that it's kind of fun to be asked to do these things.
这是对我们的嘉宾，朱莉。对，对。这算是一种爱好吗？我的意思是，你不会把它当成，你做这个不是为了谋生，因为你当演员已经赚得够多了。我想象受邀去做这些事应该挺有趣的吧。
Well, I actually, like, there was a very long time where I actually made better money doing that than my acting. Really? Yeah, a lot of that came from that. Wow. So it's like a half, it's like a, I'm like, I'm, you know, I have two jobs, I guess. I don't know, but yeah.
其实，有一段很长的时间，我通过那个赚的钱实际上比我的演艺工作还要多。真的吗？对，我很大一部分收入都来自那儿。哇。所以这就好比一半，就像是一个，我就像是，你知道的，我大概有两个工作吧。我不知道，不过是的。
And so do you love, you love all the dress up and the traveling and the... I don't love the traveling, but I, as you know, I do love, I've always loved fashion as a kid, because I always found it like a form of expression, in a way. You've got a big billboard in New York, what was it for that I've just seen recently?
那你喜欢，你喜欢所有的盛装打扮、旅行还有……我不喜欢旅行，但是，如你所知，我的确喜欢，我从小就一直很喜欢时尚，因为我总是觉得它是一种表达自我的方式，某种程度上来说。你在纽约有一块巨大的广告牌，我最近刚看到的是为什么拍的？
It was Gucci. Gucci? That was amazing, because I got to shoot with Stephen Mizell again, and he shot my first cover when I was like 21. Wow. Wow. Yeah. That's cool.
是古驰（Gucci）。古驰？那太棒了，因为我又一次有机会和斯蒂芬·梅塞尔（Steven Meisel）合作拍摄，我21岁时我的第一本杂志封面就是他拍的。哇。哇。对。太酷了。
I think it was like a year before it did Ozark. The first Ozark. Yeah. Oh my God. So long ago. That's really fucking cool. Yeah. Very, very cool.
我想那是拍《黑钱胜地》前大概一年吧。第一季《黑钱胜地》。对。天哪。好久以前了。这真的太酷了。对。非常非常酷。
Sean, you ever done a cover? Yeah. This year or no? I mean... Sorry. We need to be more specific. Yeah, just give me the year. I think you could do a cover.
肖恩，你拍过封面吗？有。今年还是没有？我是说……抱歉。我们需要更具体一点。对，直接告诉我年份。我觉得你完全可以拍个封面。
I think you can do a cover, yeah, why not? GQ, whatever. Well, Julia, when you get back in five and a half months, maybe we can say hi again. I know, I know, and I get like, I always, you know, I miss working with you. That's the thing that I want to do the most, is just, you know, work with you. That's the thing that I want to do the most, is just work with you again.
我觉得你完全可以拍个封面，对，为什么不呢？《智族GQ》，随便什么杂志。好吧，朱莉，当你五个半月后回来时，也许我们可以再次打个招呼。我知道，我知道，我感觉——我总是，你知道的，我很想念和你一起工作。我最想做的事情就是，你知道，和你一起工作。我最想做的事情就是，你知道，再次和你一起工作。
Boy, she closed her eyes when she said that. You know what I mean? It's a tell. No, I didn't. A little bit of a tell. Well, a little bit. Tell us one thing that we don't know about Jason that you experienced on.
天哪，她说完这句话时闭上了眼睛。你知道我的意思吗？这是一个破绽。不，我没有。稍微露出一 点破绽。好吧，稍微有一点。给我们讲一件我们不知道的关于杰森的事，是你在……
That was kind of fun, but also revealing and maybe embarrassing. She can't think of it. No, I can't. It's so not, Jason's probably the most, he paid me to say all of this, by the way. No, I can't. It's so not, Jason's probably the most, he paid me to say all of this by the way. No, I'm kidding. No, Jason is the most nurturing director
既有趣又具有启发性，甚至可能有点尴尬的经历。她想不出来了。不，我真的想不出来。完全不是，杰森可能是最——顺便说一句，他付钱让我说这些的。不，我真的想不出来。完全不是，杰森可能是最——顺便说一句，他付钱让我说这些的。不，开玩笑的。不，杰森是我合作过的
I've ever worked with. He's, there's this sense of safety that... That's our time. I think we just did it. You know what though, if I ever had the chance to direct Will or Sean, I'd be a fucking monster with them. Yeah, what do you think? You already have.
最有包容力的导演。他有一种安全感……我们的时间到了。我觉得我们刚刚聊完了。你知道吗，不过，如果我有一天有机会执导威尔或肖恩，我他妈会对他们像个恶魔一样严格。对，你觉得呢？你已经这么做过了。
Shut up over there, Will. You fucking directed... And we got into an argument the first time you directed Arrested Development. Yeah, because he came in all fucking pouty because... Who was it? Who lost the election? Kerry? Kerry, yeah. John who lost the election? Kerry? Kerry, yeah.
闭嘴吧，威尔。你他妈执导过……我们在你第一次执导《发展受阻》时就吵过架。对，因为他气冲冲地走进来，因为……那是谁？谁输了选举？克里？克里，对。约翰，谁输了选举？克里？克里，对。
John Kerry lost the election and old Canadian Will walks on to say all pouty about our country. Hey man, I was wearing yellow leotards and I was in a fucking banana suit, that's a true story. I had to pick you up. And Jason and I, and he picked me up with a crane and we got in an argument. Dropped you in the bay, yeah.
约翰·克里输了选举，然后老派加拿大人威尔气冲冲地走上台，对我们的国家满腹牢骚。嘿，老兄，我当时穿着黄色的紧身衣，还穿着一件该死的香蕉服，千真万确。我不得不抱起你。我和杰森，他用起重机把我吊起来，然后我们吵了起来。把你扔进海湾里了，对。
And I'm in a fucking banana suit and we're arguing outside, he's like, just do the fucking scene, I'm like, fucking banana suit and we're arguing outside. He's like, just do the fucking scene. I'm like, hey, fuck you. Yeah. Oh, I love it. Was that the last time you worked with him? That was it.
我穿着一件该死的香蕉服，我们在外面吵架，他说：“把这场戏演完就行了。”我说：“去他妈的香蕉服。”我们在外面吵架。他说：“把这场戏演完就行了。”我说：“嘿，去你的。”对。哦，我太喜欢了。那是你最后一次和他合作吗？就那一次。
As a director. Jason, as an actor and Jason directing? He's pursued me so much. I just can't make a deal. I can't, yeah, I can't make a deal. You could've closed the deal. One time we worked together as an actor, it was the smartless doc, right?
作为导演。杰森作为演员，而杰森在导演？他三番两次地游说我。我就是没法签约。我就是，对，我就是无法签约。你本可以谈成这笔交易的。我们唯一一次作为演员一起合作，是《聪明Less》的纪录片，对吧？
But that wasn't really acting. No, that wasn't acting. That was the last time we did anything, yeah. I mean, I see you every goddamn day now doing this. I'm always acting like I like you. And then Sean. This was so funny how this happened, because I remember you were doing Ozark
但那其实不算演戏。不，那不算演戏。那是我们最后一次一起搞什么东西了，对。我的意思是，现在我每天他妈的都在做这个，能见到你。我一直在假装我喜欢你。还有肖恩。这事发生得太搞笑了，因为我记得你当时在拍《黑钱胜地》，
when you started this podcast. And I remember you were like, yeah, I'm just doing something silly. It's like I'm just doing it with my friends. We're just, you know, for shits and gigs. And cut to. It's a monster. Thank you listeners.
就在你开始做这个播客的时候。我记得你当时说：“哦，我只是在搞点好玩的东西。就像是跟我朋友们一起随便做做。我们这么做，你知道的，纯粹是为了好玩和扯淡。”然后镜头一切。这简直是个庞然大物。谢谢听众们。
Nice people. I get to meet my heroes like Julia Garner. You're everything I hoped you would be, Julia. They say don't meet your heroes and you were just such a delight. Just such a delight. Love to meet you in person one day. When you get back from your movie, please look me up.
好心的人们。我有幸见到我的偶像朱莉·加纳。朱莉，你完全符合我对你的一切期望。人们都说不要去见你的偶像，而你简直是个巨大的惊喜。简直是个大惊喜。希望有一天能亲自见见你。等你拍完电影回来，请务必联系我。
I'll try, I'll find you. Yes, please do. Love you, love to your mother, love to Mark. Have a great shoot. And we're gonna see Fantastic Four. We're gonna see see the weapons. July what? July what?
我会努力的，我会找到你的。好的，请务必联系我。爱你，代我向你母亲问好，代我向马克问好。祝你拍摄顺利。我们要去看《神奇四侠》。我们要去看《武器》。7月几号？7月几号？
July 25th. July 25th. August 8th. August 8th, weapons. Yeah, and then look for the Altra she's about to, is that what you're about to go do? Yes, yep. That's going to be on Netflix.
7月25日。7月25日。8月8日。8月8日，《武器》。对，然后去找找她接下来要拍的那个……那是你要去拍的东西吗？是的，没错。那将会在Netflix上播出。
Sam Banfield, playing his wife, girlfriend? Caroline Ellison. Yeah. Wow. Very, very good wife, girlfriend? Caroline Ellison. Wow. Very, very good. That's exciting. Impressive. You're an impressive person. Congrats on everything, Julia.
扮演山姆·班克曼-弗里德（Sam Bankman-Fried）的妻子、女朋友？卡洛琳·埃利森（Caroline Ellison）。对。哇。非常、非常好的妻子、女朋友？卡洛琳·埃利森。哇。非常、非常棒。这太令人兴奋了。令人印象深刻。你是一个令人印象深刻的人。恭喜你取得的一切成就，朱莉。
Very thrilled for you. Happy for you. Love you. Go kill it. Thank you. Hit me when you're back. Yes, I will. Thank you guys so much.
为你感到非常激动。为你感到高兴。爱你。去大展身手吧。谢谢。等你回来联系我。好的，我会的。非常感谢你们。
Bye, Julia. Thank you. Bye, Julia. Bye. Oh my God, Jason. Right? By the way, thank you. Bye Julia. Bye. Oh my God, Jason. Right? By the way, you must genuinely feel a sense of pride,
再见，朱莉。谢谢。再见，朱莉。再见。天哪，杰森。对吧？顺便说一句，再见，朱莉。再见。天哪，杰森。对吧？顺便说一句，你内心深处一定会有一种自豪感，
having watched her grow from being sort of a young actor, like a young kid. She was 22. Yeah, she starts on the show, a show that you helped create and brought to life and directed and were the star of, and then she was not only amazing in it, but was recognized and had all the success
看着她从一个年轻演员、一个年轻孩子成长起来。她当时22岁。对，她参演了这个节目，一个你联合创作、赋予生命、执导并担任主演的节目，然后她在里面的表现不仅惊艳，还得到了认可，取得了所有的成功，
and has now had a huge career, and in part by all the great work she did on a show that you were instrumental in. You must feel a great sense of pride in that. Yes, but just barely. I take nothing away from her. I mean, she was like- You're not taking credit. Yeah, no, but I mean, take nothing away from her. She was like
现在拥有了庞大的职业生涯，这在很大程度上要归功于她在你发挥了关键作用的节目中做出的大量出色工作。对此你一定有一种极大的自豪感。是的，但也就一点点。我可不居功。我的意思是，她——你可别把功劳揽到自己身上。对，不，但我的意思是，别抹杀她。她当时——
Yeah, no, but I mean she I remember very very quickly We made a sort of a decision to really make that character Really drive a lot of story because she was so so good and the audience was going crazy for her and yeah it was really credit to Chris Mundy and the whole writing staff that kind of changed a lot of storylines to really utilize what a great talent she was. Yeah, she's, yeah, and a delightful person.
对，不，但我的意思是她——我记得非常非常快，我们做出了一个决定，就是真正让那个角色去推动很多剧情，因为她实在是太棒了，观众们为她疯狂，是的，这真的要归功于克里斯·芒迪（Chris Mundy）和整个编剧团队，他们改变了许多故事情节，以充分发挥她如此惊人的才华。对，她就是，是的，而且是一个非常讨人喜欢的人。
Like I'd never met her before. Oh my God, yeah. It's so, so sweet. My God. So sweet. Exact opposite of the monster, you know, Ruth was. Although, you know, she did play the character with a lot of vulnerability, but like she was really capable of just monster, Ruth, although she did play the character with a lot of vulnerability, but she was really capable of just being vicious.
就像我以前从未见过她一样。哦天哪，是的。真是太，太甜美了。天哪。太甜美了。简直是露丝这个恶魔的反面，你知道的。虽然，你知道的，她对这个角色的演绎带有很大的脆弱感，但她确实有能力表现得像个恶魔——露丝，虽然她对这个角色的演绎带有很大的脆弱感，但她确实有能力表现得极其凶残。
You love to hate her. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Love the character, I mean. But what a sweetheart, I'm so glad she's doing really well, and happy home life, happy work life, yeah. How about you, yeah, I always find it interesting when a lot of actors I know are married to musicians, you know? Like, it's a good combo.
你就是忍不住又爱又恨她。对，对，对。我是说，非常喜欢这个角色。但她真是个甜心，我很高兴她现在过得很好，家庭生活幸福，工作生活也美满，对。你呢，对，我总是觉得很有趣，我认识的很多演员都嫁给了音乐人，你知道吗？这组合挺好的。
You're married to one. Yes, I am married to one. He makes music, yeah. And Will, you do some modeling. I'm married to my work, yeah, as a model. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, what's your next, your next campaign for, Will?
你嫁给了一个。是的，我嫁给了一个。他创作音乐，对。威尔，你拍一些模特广告。我是嫁给了我的工作，对，作为一个模特。对。对。威尔，你的下一个，下一个代言活动是什么？
My next campaign is for laxative. Okay. And I've moved into a different category at this stage of my life. Something for the seniors? Yeah, which I think, and now we live in this world, and so anyway, so it's like... So those photo shoots gotta be shorter then, no? When the poster is just, I give a shit, a lot, You know? And it's going pretty well. Yeah, it sounds like it's going smooth. Yeah.
我的下一个代言活动是关于泻药的。好吧。在我人生的这个阶段，我已经进入了一个不同的类别。专为老年人设计的？对，我觉得，现在我们生活在这样一个世界里，所以不管怎样，这就像是……所以那些照片拍摄应该会更短吧？当海报上的文案只是“我挺能拉的，真的”，你知道吗？进展得相当顺利。对，听起来进展很顺利。对。
Hey, yeah. I got new glasses. Okay. Oh boy. So you got the kind that you got. And so working bifocal backwards. That's right. Oh, well you ruined it.
嘿，对。我换了新眼镜。好吧。哦天哪。所以你买的是那种……也就是双焦点倒过来用。没错。哦，好吧，你把它剧透了。
No, no, no, go ahead. Oh, I don't think I ruined it. I don't think you were ahead of anybody on that. The second you. No, no, go ahead. Oh, I don't think I ruined it. I don't think you were ahead of anybody The second you said glasses, but go fuck a story about your new spec. They really are new I just got yesterday are they all right? Was it one prescription or two because the bottoms are what are they? No, it's not the bottoms are it by having to it makes them by The buys so angry By having two, it makes them... Bye, Focals! Do you not get that? Well, you said that the bye is so angry.
不，不，不，你接着说。哦，我觉得我没剧透。我不觉得你在这个上面抢在了任何人前面。就在你……不，不，接着说。哦，我觉得我没剧透。我不觉得你在这个上面抢在了任何人前面。就在你说了“眼镜”这个词之后——去你妈的关于你新眼镜的故事吧。它们真的是新的，我昨天刚配的。它们还好吗？是一个屈光度还是两个？因为下半部分是，它们是什么？不，不是下半部分，它是……由于有两个，所以让它们变成了——拜，双焦点！你没听懂吗？好吧，你说那个“拜”是因为太生气了。
Because you just don't get it when it is bye! Goodbye. Goodbye. Smart. Less. Smart.ess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess.
因为当它是“拜”的时候你根本没get到！再见。再见。聪明。Less。聪明。Less。聪明Less。聪明Less。聪明Less。聪明Less。聪明Less。聪明Less。
SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry and Rob Armjarff. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《聪明Less》由贝内特·巴比科（Bennett Barbico）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·阿尔姆贾夫（Rob Armjarff）100%有机手工制作。聪明Less。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。